Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu u k w unsere kleine welt mein name ist tim bridle und hier ist wieder das corona weekly.
Mit mir und mit pavel hallo pavel ja
und wir so unsere art ist wollen wir das zahlen und das digitale geschehen ein bisschen begleiten
und vielleicht auch ein wenig diskutieren was sonst noch so rund um die ganze corona debatte herum gerade herumgeschaut und herum diskutiert wird.
Hat ja nicht so richtig nachgelassen das thema kann man nicht wirklich sagen durfte also dominiert die öffentliche debatte immer noch.
Auch wenn die leute jetzt vielleicht schon mehr und mehr anfangen.
So auf andere sachen wieder einzuscheren aber der öffentlichkeit geht's heiß her insbesondere unser spezial unser aller spezial freund herr trosten.
Kommt nicht aus den medien heraus und liefert sich dann interessanten battle mit der bild-zeitung.
Und mittlerweile auch mit seinem fellow podcast hätte ich fast gesagt jetzt auch noch mit diesem keko leo.
Ja geht's heiß her oder.
Ja es ist schon unschön unappetitlich finde ich was da passiert so weil,
man muss ja erstmal sehen so der wissenschaftliche prozess läuft ja so da
packt man gerade in dieser zeit packt man halt
viele studien oder ergebnisse erstmal auf einen brief als vor veröffentlichung
damit das halt debattiert werden kann wo man dann in der lage ist auch noch feedback aus der community ein
zu holen und dann ja das ganze zu verbessern bis es dann zu einer endgültigen publikation
wird und aus ja irgendwelchen
gründen über die man natürlich spekulieren kann oder die vielleicht auch teilweise auf der hand liegen grätscht dann jetzt völlig unqualifiziert die bildzeitung.
In diesem prozess hinein hat auf dem weg wohl auch noch ja eine ganze reihe von leuten getäuscht
die sich dann anschließend distanziert haben ja von dem was sie laut bild gesagt haben sollen und.
In der sache geht es halt um die frage sind kinder jetzt
genauso ansteckend oder weniger ansteckend als erwachsene und da warten wir weiß gar nicht ob wir hier darüber gesprochen haben aber es war ja,
ich vermute schon.
Jedenfalls ist die studie geht ja darüber dass die proben die im
labor eingelaufen sind bei der charité die betreiben ja auch einen recht großes tests labor und hatten dementsprechend auch zugriff
auf eine größere menge an proben und haben dann ja die virus konzentration analysiert und hatten dann so ich glaube vierzig kinder
drin ungefähr problem ist halt kinder sind halt selten in diesen studien da muss man schon
eine menge fälle haben und untersuchen um auf vierzig kinder tatsächlich zu
kommen also ich glaube das waren insgesamt mehrere tausend proben die da analysiert werden mussten und dann.
Egal jetzt der streit darum die schlussfolgerung aus der aus der studie haben kinder nun weniger virus oder haben sie halt mehr virus und
die schlüsse die jetzt das team um trosten draus geschlossen hat war es gibt keine signifikanten unterschiede
was sie halt gemacht haben zu dem sex was eigentlich auch nicht ganz blöd ist sie haben jetzt nicht einfach
junge mit alten verglichen sondern haben halt altersklassen gemacht und haben halt sämtliche altersklassen gegeneinander verglichen um zu sehen ob es da irgendwo sagen eine kurve gibt weil es bald bekannt
auch von anderen themen anderen viralen epidemien des
je nach alter.
Leute unterschiedlich stark betroffen sind oder unterschiedlich stark reagieren da gibt es recht komplexe kurven und zusammenhänge und ja deswegen haben die das halt so gemacht und jetzt hat halt ein englischer forscher gesagt,
okay wenn man aber jetzt nur die kinder nimmt.
Dann nur die älteren und das mit direkt miteinander vergleicht dann käme schon was signifikant ist dabei raus nämlich dass kinder irgendwie zwanzig oder dreißig prozent
größenordnungsmäßigen weniger infektiös ich würde sagen.
So gefühlt wenn ich mir das ja wenn ich mir das durchlese so wer hat wer hat eigentlich recht denn liegt wahrscheinlich die wahrheit,
irgendwo in der mitte aber die zahlen sind halt nicht so super belastbar.
Aber ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen dass jetzt das team um trosten irgendeinen offensichtlichen anfängerfehler gemacht hat
oder so sondern das war eigentlich methodisch schon korrekt und sagen jetzt der engländer ja.
Kann man natürlich so machen aber das problem ist wenn man so einen ganz einfachen vergleich macht wiederum da da können auch noch andere dinge mit mit reinspielen und.
Gut da spielen wahrscheinlich auch andere dinge mit mit rein aber letztlich ist ja die,
die frage also worum es geht sind kinder weniger ansteckend oder nicht und da finde ich
liegt so die beweislast sage ich mal auf der seite derer die des sozusagen zeigen wollen dass sie weniger ansteckend sind es gibt zwar bei anderen krankheiten aber erstmal,
finde ich dir die volt ist dass man davon ausgeht dass eigentlich erstmal alle personen mehr oder weniger gleich ansteckend sind wobei man dann in die einzelnen fälle rein,
guckt jetzt auch in anderen studien stellt man fest dass es da auch,
riesige schwankungen gibt in der in der viruslast bei den tests also es ist das das schwankt sei mal zwischen würde ich sagen zehn und zehn millionen so ungefähr.
Das problem ist dass natürlich bei der entnahme ist die frage wie wie und wo werden abstriche gemacht weil da ist halt auch bekannt dass sehr stark davon abhängt
wie man den abstrich nimmt wie viel wie hoch die konzentration ist das zweite ist die frage in welcher phase der erkrankung befindet sich jemand weil da die variiert halt dann
auch mit der virus konzentration das heißt es gibt da ganz ganz viele faktoren die das halt echt schwierig machen.
Vor allem war er auch seine aussage nicht mit das ist nicht so sondern es war nur so auf den zahlen die wir hier sehen können wir darüber keine finale aussage machen.
Und das ist ja auch nochmal so eine so eine feinheit also es ist ja gar nicht mal so eine behauptung mit ist nicht so sondern es war eher so ein naja also.
Die zahlen geben so nicht her das kann nach wie vor sein oder nicht sein aber mit mit dieser analyse können wir das so erstmal nicht bestätigen.
Das sind natürlich alles so details ja am ende keiner mehr wahrnimmt oder zumindest bei der bild-zeitung keiner wahrnehmen möchte.
Und da muss man erstens sagen also da liegt
ganz definitiv ich sag mal die beweislast bei den kritikern und die sind dem beweis bisher schuldig geblieben und wenn sie irgendwie können noch nicht auf der einen seite seine zahlen
kritisieren und seine auswertung kritisieren und dann auch noch behaupten es wäre aber trotzdem so dass kinder
weniger infektiös sind ich meine da passt doch einfach für mich irgendwas nicht zusammen und da muss ich sagen würde ich mich doch
klar auf der seite von trosten positionieren was jetzt meine meinung angeht wer in,
dieser wissenschaftlichen oder auch durch die bild jetzt unwissenschaftliche auseinandersetzung
jetzt der wahrheit am nächsten sagen wir es mal so.
Also aus meiner sicht ist das ist das,
höchst verwerflich was die bildzeitung da gemacht hat.
Das ist halt ein machtest ne also das ist sie sind halt normalerweise gewohnt hier auch einfach da mal behaupten zu können was sie wollen.
Das ist ja auch immer so dieses wer sich mit der bildzeitung einlässt.
Riskiert damit auch immer letzten endes von deren aussage abzuhängen ob man jetzt top oder flop ist das kann sich dann je nachdem wie es ihnen gerade passt von heute auf morgen auch mal erinnern.
Und wenn es hin und her geht dann ist das für sie auch gut weil das schafft dann interesse und das schafft dann leser.
Gab ja immer irgendwie den spruch dann gegen die bild-zeitung kann kein deutscher kanzler regieren oder so.
Genau das würden sie natürlich auch gerne so beibehalten.
Nur ist es jetzt halt ganz interessant zu sehen dass der trost mittlerweile so viele popularität hat und vor allem auch mit seinem podcast so ein eigenes outlet hat.
Das seitdem natürlich seine eigene medien macht jetzt auch dagegen halten kann.
Und ich.
Denke mal ja dadurch dass er auch eben so lange und so viel und so ungefiltert und auch doch so vorsichtig im großen und ganzen vermeidet
ist ja extrem sich aus dem fenster zu legen also von all denen die da in der öffentlichkeit unterwegs sind
ist er definitiv derjenige aus meiner wahrnehmung der sich der wirklich da am vorsichtigsten formuliert.
Agiert und am am wenigsten pusht oder druck macht sondern sich sich da echt zurücknimmt,
ich glaube das merken die leute auch die ihnen zuhören ich meine reicht fast einen podcast aus um zu merken das ist kein schwätzer sondern es ist jemand der doch mit sehr viel bedacht formuliert und das gefällt mir halt
einfach das finde ich bewundernswert.
Ja dann würde ich vorschlagen.
Gucken wir doch mal auf die aktuellen zahlen es hat sich ja einiges getan und auch da gab es dann auch noch ein paar bemerkenswerte öffentliche diskussionen drum herum.
Da gehen wir dann auch gleich noch drauf ein so thüringen etcetera so du hast ja jetzt
fleißig weiter deine tabelle dann risiko tabelle gefüttert und vor allem auch die aktuellen zahlen dir angeschaut die das l k i rausgehauen hat was was ist denn passiert in den letzten wochen.
Grob gesagt erstmal sagen die situation im großen und ganzen wird besser.
Deutschlandweit aber es gibt einfach oben an der spitze so eine reihe von sag mal problembezirk die zwar auch.
Graduell besser werden aber irgendwie dass dort nicht unter kontrolle ist so das kann man kann man sagen dass es gibt gegenden da ist es außer kontrolle und.
Aktuell wenn man blick so auf die top ten oder top zwanzig wirft,
so ist in bayern definitiv am meisten los also bayern ist,
unbestrittene tabellenführer also die hälfte der plätze in den top ten geht an bayerische
landkreise so mit lichtenfels auf platz eins und regensburg auf platz zwei was so dass das risiko angeht wo auch die zahlen
weiter nach oben gegangen sind von der vorletzten auf die letzte woche.
Und dann ja haben wir irgendwie bei zweimal coburg noch drin landkreis und
stadtkreis auf platz fünf und sieben hof auf platz sechs rosenheim auf platz siebzehn immer noch und dann,
neustadt auf platz zwanzig so das ist ja so bayern.
Dach auf platz fünfzehn hast du vergessen dachau auf platz fünfzehn.
Dachau hab ich auch noch für ok genau dachau ist ist halt so ein aufsteiger der
da war es eigentlich ganz entspannt aber da muss es irgendwie einen kleinen ausbruch gegeben haben siebzehn neue fälle vorher gab es so gut wie gar nichts das hat dachau mal eben
vom ende der tabelle dreihundertsechsundsechzig plätze nach vorne katapultiert.
Kleiner ausbruch ja und ja bei neustadt weißt du eigentlich wie oft es wie viel viel neustadt es gibt in deutschland.
Viele zwanzig.
Einundzwanzig.
Einundzwanzig mal neustadt und dem fall ist das neustadt an der waldnaab sonst wenn man neustadt sagt.
Kriegen gleich alle panik.
Ist es genau.
Oh gott neustadt.
Ja und,
ansonsten der der zweite am zweiten meisten in den top ten vertretene kandidat ist halt
weiterhin thüringen mit den altbekannten namen sonneberg und greiz und jetzt ist halt gera
auch noch dazu gekommen in der woche also das sind so die die thüringer ja top gemeinden und insgesamt ich meine gut muss halt sehen.
Also die landkreise in bayern also coburg ist jetzt auch nicht weit so weit entfernt von jetzt den.
Den thüringischen gemeinden interessant ist aber dort auch dass es eben nicht so ist.
Das jetzt unbedingt benachbarte gemeinden.
So gemeinsam dort aktivität ist sondern es gibt da auch teilweise echt scharfe grenzen so auch in einem land von einem landkreis zum zum anderen so in einem richtig was los ist und im anderen nicht also.
Es hängt vermutlich auch damit zusammen wie stark der austausch
zwischen den verschiedenen gemeinden nehme ich mal an gibt es halt gegen den lassen sich die landkreise nicht wirklich auseinander dividieren da ist wahrscheinlich wohnen und arbeiten und so so verteilt dass es eigentlich
fast ein landkreis ist oder da entwickeln scheint sich das auch ähnlich zu entwickeln.
Oft das infektionsgefahr sehen werden es dann andere gibt wo aus welchen gründen auch immer ja es.
Sehr viel ruhiger ist.
Ja aber so coburg hof sonnenberg das hängt aber auch wirklich alles zusammen und ist halt auch an der grenze.
Zu zu türingen also das ist alles schon da ist schon so ein hotspots in der oberpfalz also das das lässt sich schon relativ klar sagen,
und ja ich weiß gar nicht ob man das noch irgendeine über kategorie gibt halt leider zwischen landkreis und.
Land dann keine weitere klammer also wenn man nochmal so obergruppen hätte
von bestimmten regionen wo man sagen kann okay hier das ist sozusagen dieser betrachtung
bereich die hängen hier kulturell verkehrstechnisch oberzentrum mäßig alle zusammen dann wäre das wahrscheinlich auch nochmal eine ganz interessante größe ich weiß gar nicht gibt's da irgendwie sowas.
Franken man sagt halt oberpfalz aber ist das in irgendeiner form auch eine eine behördliche struktur der irgendeine stelle abgebildet ist.
Es gibt noch irgendwie sogenannte regierungsbezirke aber ich weiß auch nicht ob sie überall gibt
und so also da gibt's noch glaube ich schon was was dazwischen aber das ist halt nicht unbedingt so prominent aber ich glaube das sind die sogenannten regierungsbezirke die noch dazwischen liegen als,
verwaltungseinheit oder so zumindest in großen flächenländern also in nordrhein-westfalen weiß ich gibt es halt.
Regierungsbezirke weil da musste man dann in manchen angelegenheiten musste man sich dann an den regierungsbezirk finden die regierungsbezirke arnsberg war damals immer das ding als ich noch,
bevor ich nach berlin gezogen bin ja.
So ja und ansonsten ja düsseldorf ist irgendwie platz vierzehn und kleve auf neunzehn und nordrhein-westfalen ist halt mit borken
irgendwie auf platz drei noch vertreten also da ist einiges ja sonst noch niedersachsen
mit leer auf platz zehn und osnabrück auf platz elf und ansonsten.
Eine ein baden-württembergische kreis wenn ich das richtig sehe,
nämlich pforzheim und ja falz haben wir noch meins drin so,
alle und gut in sachsen sehe ich gerade haben wir noch den den vogtlandkreis auf platz achtzehn.
Sagen die andere hälfte der bundesländer,
muss man sagen oder über die hälfte der bundesländer ist halt in den top zwanzig gar nicht vertreten mit irgendwelchen landkreisen
und das spiegelt sich denn auch wenn man die gesamtzahlen für die für die länder.
Sich anschaut oder das länderranking untereinander dann haben wir halt im risiko ranking nach wie vor bremen ganz oben,
aber bremen ist ja schon so ein bisschen vielleicht eine spezial situation aber nichtsdestotrotz bremen ist halt vorne aber an zweiter stelle in kommt halt jetzt schon thüringen in meiner risikobewertung,
vor bayern sogar noch polen bayern irgendwie mehr hotspots hat,
ist es so dass in bayern die zahlen,
etwas stärker zurückgehen ich meine die haben bayern und thüringen liegen halt.
Auf also haben fast so bei den fällen pro hunderttausend
sind die sagen fast identisch sechs komma sechs haben beide in den letzten sieben tagen also sechs komma sechs fälle je hunderttausend einwohner
entwickeln sich sagen ähnlich gehen halt irgendwie beide leicht runter,
aber ja in bayern gehen die fällen ticken schneller runter.
Kurzer nachtrag bevor ich wieder in den kommentaren darauf hingewiesen werde die region nicht gerade ansprache ist nicht die oberpfalz sondern oberfranken.
Ob
Und außerdem habe ich gerade mal mit den regierungsbezirken die du erlebt hast nachgeschlagen ist ganz interessant und wer vielleicht mal eine klammer die du auch noch mit einbauen könntest und deine tabelle sozusagen als,
weitere unterscheidung innerhalb von bundesländern tatsächlich gibt es drei bundesländer die keine einteilung in regierungsbezirke kennen.
Das nämlich thüringen brandenburg und.
Mecklenburg-vorpommern die vier und schleswig-holstein und natürlich die stadt starten nicht.
Allerdings haben gerade die großen flächenländer eben mit der ausnahme von mvv und brandenburg ganz interessante unterteilung also sachsen zum beispiel teilt sich in.
Leipzig dresden chemnitz und bayern zum beispiel mitunter frank oberfranken mittelfranken oberpfalz schwaben.
Oberbayern niederbayern ist also noch mal eine ganz interessante gruppierung um einfach auch nochmal da die hotspots besser vielleicht herauslesen zu können das könnte ganz sportlich sein ne.
Klar saarland ist auch nicht weiter unterteilt aber niedersachsen hat ein paar unterteilung und ja alle anderen eigentlich auch auch nordrhein-westfalen.
Das wäre vielleicht mal zu erwägen das nochmal mit einzubauen.
Wobei die liste die wunschliste ist halt sehr lang sozusagen auch meine wunschliste.
Was die seite angeht die performance mal ein bisschen noch zu beschleunigen ja,
zurück zu den bundesländern interessant ist dass jetzt nur noch bremen thüringen bayern niedersachsen und hessen eigentlich schlechter sind als der bundesschnitt und alle anderen
länder sind,
von der risikobewertung her besser als der bundesdurchschnitt das heißt sagen diese vier wobei wahrscheinlich bayern da eine menge ausmachen,
dürfte wegen der einfach großen bevölkerung in ihrem dreizehn millionen einwohner das wirkt sich natürlich dann dann erheblich
aus niedersachsen auch mit acht millionen so ist definitiv auf dem niedersachsen und hessen
halt auch nochmal sechs also die ziehen jedenfalls den den schnitt deutlich nach oben
und ja ganz unten halt sachsen-anhalt und vor allem mecklenburg-vorpommern muss man sagen es hat seit einer woche also in der letzten woche nicht einen einzigen fall gemeldet
zweimal so formulieren weil das heißt jetzt nicht dass es dort keine,
infektionen gibt wir haben nur keine festgestellt so ob es dort welche gibt wissen wir,
eigentlich nicht aber es ist auf jeden fall schon mal einen sehr beruhigendes zeichen an.
Schon mal ein bundesland haben,
wo nicht viel los ist und.
Ja so dann natürlich der,
traditionelle blick auf berlin nochmal weil man berlin nicht ist finde ich nicht nur interessant weil wir beide,
dort wohnen sondern weil berlin auch die einzige jetzt mit troposphäre ist wo es auch
eine aufgliedern
in die verschiedenen bezirke gibt was es halt ein bisschen interessanter macht die zahlen von berlin anzugucken wie sich das halt in so einer eigentlich zusammenhängenden stadt wo es nicht wirklich grenzen gibt,
wie sich das geschehen dort entwickelt und,
ja berlin kann man sagen ist auch erstmal als ganzes entwickelt sich auch.
Besser jetzt wieder ist also ein vierundzwanzig plätze abgestiegen in der in der gesamtlistenpreis
und auch spandau was halt lange ziemlich weit vorne war hat es offensichtlich unter kontrolle gekriegt also da sind
die zahlen jetzt drastisch gefallen so von sechsunddreißig auf sieben fälle in der vorwoche
ja dafür ist jetzt der bezirk lichtenberg irgendwie ganz nach oben an die an die spitze der tabelle was die berliner bezirke angeht
gesprungen weil dort einfach ja es von zehn auf dreiundzwanzig fälle hochgegangen ist in der letzten woche und
auch neukölln das ja schon auch immer relativ weit vorne rangiert kommt nicht zur ruhe sondern auch da ist halt von zwanzig auf sechsundzwanzig fälle.
Hochgegangen,
charlottenburg-wilmersdorf gehen die zahlen auch noch hoch oder sind hochgegangen von haben sich sogar fast verdoppelt von sieben auf vierzehn fälle,
in allen anderen bezirken aber sinken die zahlen zum teil doch recht deutlich.
Zum verständnis deiner bemerkung berlin sei vierundzwanzig plätze nach unten gegangen wir haben ja nur sechzehn bundesländer das ist jetzt kein vergleich der bundesländer was du meinst du hast ja die bundesländer mit den landkreisen zusammen in eine tabelle
das ist dann immer in bezug auf die gesamtzahl zu sehen aller landkreise plus eben der länder und deutschland selber auch nochmal von daher ist es nicht so anhaltspunkt wie sich das verhält und sagt
eigentlich nur aus wo sich quasi das landesmittel befindet und dass man auch landkreise selber zuordnen kann so wie weit ist denn ein landkreis von einem bundesland entfernt etcetera
in der liste der länder wiederum liegt damit berlin so irgendwo in der mitte.
Ist etwas besser als nordrhein-westfalen und was halt ja also abgesehen davon dass bremen ich meine bremen als bundesland zu,
betrachten an der stelle als es ist eins aber es ist halt nicht so ein riesen kluster wie jetzt die anderen und hat halt gerade mal irgendwie zweiundachtzigtausend einwohner halt irgendwo.
Es ist halt so.
Es halt bremen und bremerhaven irgendwie zusammen.
Ja man müsste es halt einfach irgendwie in niedersachsen mit reinnehmen das hören die jetzt wahrscheinlich gerne aber.
Es nicht die bremer hören ja.
Aber auch dann sieht's nicht sehr viel besser aus für die also wenn sie immer noch ganz vorne mit dabei und ja nur sachsen-anhalt und mecklenburg-vorpommern ist wirklich richtig gut.
Und der rest naja entwickelt sich.
Genau ja und dann zum schluss noch ein blick auf die.
Entwicklung in gesamtdeutschland jetzt die die die summe und auch da.
Ist die zahl der fälle jetzt weiter zurückgegangen im sieben tages mittel und.
Liegt jetzt also es sieht mein sieben tage über sieben tage gemittelten.
Liegt jetzt bei null komma acht fünf aktuell also es geht weiter zurück und.
Man muss aber jetzt dazu sagen dass.
Die testphase also ob jetzt mehr oder weniger tests gemacht werden beeinflusst ja sagen auch die zahl der der positiven.
Fälle es liegt ja auf der hand dass wenn ich mehr teste finde ich auch mehr so,
in der regel jedenfalls sei denn es gibt keine dunkelziffer so dann wäre es so dann wenn ich dann mehr teste finde ich nicht mehr da geht nur meine rate und aber dem ist das ist definitiv nicht der fall oder.
Sehr sehr wahrscheinlich nicht der fall weil ich
jetzt auf eine ganz interessante sache gestoßen bin auch in dieser woche über die ich noch nicht geredet habe beziehungsweise wir hatten uns vor einem monat glaube ich mal
auch das für die zahl der toten angesehen da hatte ich mal damit,
begonnen und hatten die dann so entsprechend zeitlich ineinander geschoben um zu gucken.
Ja wie entwickelt sich das und damals,
war das noch nicht so auffällig aber jetzt so nach ja vier wochen später kann man sehen dass es 'ne doch sehr starke korrelation.
Zwischen dem auf-und ab der kurve
der kurve für die zahl der verstorbenen und für die zahl der infizierten und,
die sind nur so um scheinlösungen zwei drei tage auch noch gegeneinander verschoben zu sein aber das irre ist dass
in der regel
die zahl der toten so zwei bis drei tage früher angefangen hat zu steigen als die zahl der infizierten also und das kann natürlich erstmal nicht sein weil wenn sich jemand infiziert,
also eigentlich müssten die kurven wenn du sie wenn die reale infektion abbilden müsste halt die zahl der toten so fünfzehn zwanzig tage hinter der zahl der infizierten herr,
laufen tut sie aber nicht so die einzige erklärung die es dafür gibt
ist dass dieses auf-und ab vom r selbst im sieben tage mittel was wir hier jetzt gesehen haben in den letzten sechs wochen.
Ist sehr wahrscheinlich zum überwiegenden teil ein erhebung artefakt also sprich,
es hat was damit zu tun wie und wann die,
tests durchgeführt werden und die tests ausgeweitet werden oder zurückgehen oder wieder ausgeweitet werden oder wieder zurückgehen das scheint
die kurve auch der toten mit zu beeinflussen,
was vermutlich damit zusammenhängt dass entweder posthum getestet wird oder die leute sehr kurz erst vor ihrem tod getestet.
Werden sehr vielleicht sehr spät ins krankenhaus kommen und dann aus irgendeinem grund noch diese meldungen dann schneller beim eintreffen als die meldungen bei den infizierten,
was auch durchaus sein kann weil wenn jemand stirbt dann liegt ja einen testergebnis schon vor während wenn jetzt jemand kommt und sich,
meldet da muss der ersten test gemacht werden und dann muss das testergebnis abgewartet werden insofern könnte das sagen auch plausibel,
sein so.
War ja im prinzip wieder bei diesem now casting also dem dem herausrechnen der tatsächlichen erkrankungen daten
aus den gemeldeten zahlen dass man sich eben nicht an den meldedaten orientiert wie wir das ja hier in dieser risiko tabelle vorfinden ne das ist ja quasi dann wir wollen in die zukunft blicken und,
now casting dazu machen aus verschiedenen gründen wir schon
mehrfach diskutiert haben würde jetzt nicht unbedingt zu sehr viel bringen aber bei dieser korrelation zwischen tatsächlichen infizierten und tatsächlich gestorbenen da ist es natürlich schon sinnvoll wenn man jetzt das tatsächliche erkrankungen datum mit dem tatsächlichen sterbedatum in verbindung bringen würde.
Ja das ja dann würde man wahrscheinlich diese diese.
Dieser anstiege es hilft nicht nee es hilft ja nicht weil,
ist ja unabhängig davon also die sozusagen auch beim infektionsstation selbst wenn ich das verwende,
wird ja die zahl,
durch die zahl der tests beeinflusst kriege ich dann zwar eine etwas andere zeitliche verschiebung wahrscheinlich hin aber
sagen damit löse ich das problem der schwankenden testphase oder des des sagen sich ändernden testregion kriegt
man dadurch nicht gelöst und in konsequenz was jetzt letztlich wissen was alles wie die die.
Die zahlen die wir täglich lesen also die meldung ok heute so und so viel neue infizierte sohn zu viel neu gestorben sind durch jetzt durch so viele.
Faktoren verzerrt und beeinflusst also zum einen.
Tests was wir gerade hatten aber dann auch das ganze thema melde verzögerung und da kann man vielleicht dann.
Später noch noch dazu auch in dem zusammenhang mit diesem artikel aber.
Unterm strich kann man sagen,
sind die zahlen mit denen wir gerade hantieren und anhand derer man versucht zu beurteilen was jetzt passiert sind.
Viel viel.
Problematischer noch als ich das vor ein paar wochen gedacht hätte und tatsächlich würde ich sogar sagen sind erbe rechnungen
eigentlich nicht seriös möglich mit diesen zahlen eigentlich kann man sagen mit den zahlen
kann man den reproduktion faktor schlichtweg nicht berechnen man kann nicht mal sich darauf verlassen
wenn die zahlen hochgehen ob sie wirklich hochgegangen sind oder ob sich ob nur die tests ausgeweitet wurden wenn die zahlen runtergehen
ob sie wirklich runtergegangen sind oder nur weniger getestet wurde oder wenn sie hochgehen hat da jetzt irgendein land plötzlich einen schwung
von altdaten nachgemeldet die eigentlich irrelevant sind also dieses am ende des tages man deswegen ist es auch in der risiko tabelle was man halt,
gucken kann ist okay wir hat's in der vorwoche ausgesehen wie sieht's in dieser woche aus,
und sich dann noch die zahl der tests anzuschauen und dann zu sagen okay die zahlen sind zwar runtergegangen aber wahrscheinlich nicht so stark oder weil,
test ausweitung und so aber ja also ganz ganz schwierig wir haben haben da ja.
So gewaltige schätzfrage fehler dass
auch keinen sinn macht und und speziell auch das berliner was da vermeldet wird kann ich halt überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen irgendwelche erwerten von über eins.
Die es angeblich in berlin gegeben haben soll finde ich nirgendwo also ich.
Dann gefragt halt auch auf twitter berlin irgendwie andere zahlen hat oder als das r k i oder
wie auch immer jedenfalls das scheint mir da scheint mir völlige fantasiezahlen zu sein die da in der presse kursieren so also keine ahnung wie die draufkommen.
Was ist denn dein dein für berlin also was hast du das irgendwie gebildet.
Ja liegt im prinzip auch im bundesdurchschnitt lass mich mal eben kurz das r w in umrechnen.
Null komma neun null komma neun ungefähr würde ich sagen.
Ist jetzt die diese diese.
Das wöchentliche verhältnis genau das ist das verhältnis wie sich von einer woche die zahl der fälle,
in der verhältnis zu anderen woche oder letzten sieben tage versus die sieben tage davor und.
Weil die produktionszeit aber kleiner ist sozusagen muss man und nicht nicht die sieben tage die wir beträgt die wir hier betrachten bei dieser verhältnis bildung.
Kann man aber einfach die wurzel ziehen aus dem r w und kommt dann ungefähr auf eine vergleichbare zahl die halt mit dem vergleichbar ist.
Also null komma neun also unter eins aber.
Unter eins.
Toll aber auch nicht so schlimm wie sie berichtet wurde.
Also nicht wesentlich schlechter als im bund genau.
Also wenn ich dich richtig verstehe kann man festhalten.
Das zahlenwerk ist von daher etwas wackelig derzeit einerseits weil wir es generell mit niedrigen zahlen zu tun haben das hatten wir ja schon mehrfach.
Aber auch weil bestimmte faktoren fehlen und konkret sind es halt jetzt diese testfahrt die halt nur als wochen summe bereitgestellt werden.
Aber eben nicht in einer höheren auflösung vorliegen und generell nicht unbedingt teil der daten sind.
Und im prinzip kann man rudimentär
dienstags wenn die zahlen gemeldet werden kann man dann rückwirkend so ein bisschen die zahlen der letzten woche tatsächlich einschätzen also ob ob sie jetzt wirklich zurückgegangen sind oder stärker oder weniger stark aber
das problem ist man kann es halt auch nicht genau auseinander rechnen weil.
Man nicht weiß welche tests eigentlich,
warum gemacht worden ist hatten wir glaube ich auch schon mal beim letzten mal das das thema wenn man das man könnte es ein bisschen besser auseinander rechnen wenn man einfach nur wüsste.
Warum
ist der test eigentlich gemacht worden warum es ja veranlasst worden also sprich ist es jemand mit symptomen der sich beim amt gemeldet hat
ist es jemand der im krankenhaus erneut getestet wurde und um um festzustellen ob er jetzt gesund ist
ist es irgendein tests eines symptom losen der nur getestet wurde weil er in einer risikogruppe ist oder
wurde er getestet weil er kontakt zu jemandem hatte der positiv war.
Ja all diese dinge
werden halt wichtig zu wissen um sagen vergleichbare zahlen herzustellen von einer woche zur anderen oder von einem tag zum anderen sogar wobei im moment sagen kann,
tageszahlen kann man eigentlich komplett knicken im moment also alles andere als einen sieben tages schnitt.
Rückwirkend zu betrachten kann man auch vergessen wegen der wiederum wochentags
schwankungen die da drin sind so 'ne neue zahl an einem tag ist halt bestenfalls ein weiterer daten punkt der den wochenschau bitten bisschen nach oben oder nach unten zieht aber für sich genommen
ist eine tageszeit auch komplett wertlos kam vergessen sagt irgendwie gar nichts aus.
Und das wäre ja eigentlich eine schöne sache wenn man das könnte also.
Wenn man dann auch sehr viel mehr rückschlüsse drauf führen könnte das haben wir auch früher schon mal besprochen so wann passieren denn die dinge passieren die am wochenende passieren die in der woche was was sind die gründe dafür kann man da irgendwas draus.
Ablesen.
Ich denke ja das wäre das problem mit den daten wo wir glaube ich schon seit seit der weiß nicht ob wir seit der ersten ich glaube nicht seit der ersten sendung wahrscheinlich seit der dritten glaube ich so ein bisschen,
wer beklagen wie dort die situation aussieht.
Hat jetzt hat jetzt mittlerweile auch mehr und mehr ja die presse draufgeschaut.
Und da beschäftigen sich natürlich auch ganz viele mit den daten und bei mich wundert dass.
Erst so spät kommt gut es gab offenen brief den wir diskutiert
hatten den offenen brief der daten journalisten ans mit ganz konkreten punkten die vorgeschlagen wurden die sind wir beim letzten mal auch durchgegangen
der halt sehr sinnvoll ist ach ich habe und es gibt übrigens hatte mir jetzt jemand geschickt.
Tatsächlich von der ard jetzt ein archiv mit den kompletten daten- seit
anfang märz oder so das habe ich das da würde ich dann gestern darauf aufmerksam gemacht und habe es mir halt gleich heute.
Gezogen also werde dann wohl schauen dass also werde wohl dann.
Die auswertung noch verbessern können jetzt.
Über den gesamten zeitraum.
War das jetzt war das jetzt ein ein offizielles archiv oder so eine so ein private sammlung.
Na wie gesagt von der von irgendwelchen leuten bei der ard bei den irgendwelche daten journalisten von der ard die ard hat tatsächlich auch ein gitter präposition.
Und irgendjemand muss die dort gesammelt haben oder.
Und hat das glaube ich und hat das jetzt ins gitter gestellt und aktualisieren die auch ständig was.
Und das sind die daten aus denen du dann tabelle baust.
Genau genau und die hatte ich jetzt nur rückwirkend.
Bis zum achtundzwanzigsten vierten glaube ich und da kriege ich jetzt einen monat mehr an,
daten wobei mittlerweile der der sozusagen habe ich ja auch fast einen monat zusammen das.
Hilft dann auf jeden fall schon aber ist natürlich schöner die möglichst komplett zu haben weil wenn ich wirkend schöne auswertungen drauf fahren.
Es gab dann ein artikel.
Beim beim bayrischen rundfunk ja auch sehr hinterher sind auch bei diesem open corona data appell ganz vorne mit dabei.
Die auch jetzt nochmal auf dieses spezifische problem mit den meldedaten und den gesundheitsämtern eingegangen ist wir.
Hatten das ja schon besprochen beziehungsweise dir ist das ja schon aufgefallen dass es nach rückmeldungen auf deine tabelle so eine diskrepanz gab die sich dann herausgestellt hat als.
Die zahlen die gesamtzahlen zu den landkreisen die das veröffentlicht berücksichtigt nur.
Gemeldete fälle wenn die fälle selber in den letzten sieben tagen überhaupt stattfanden.
Und alles was elter war viel da komplett raus.
Und der hat sich das auch nochmal genauer angeschaut einen längeren artikel dazu gemacht und mal ein paar auswertung gemacht.
Und festgestellt dass also das wirklich ein wirklich großes problem ist und dass diese ganzen verzögerungen
ja doch teilweise ziemlich krass sind also es gibt einfach landkreise die so spät melden.
Dass sie da mehr oder weniger alles alles verzerren.
Und ich habe bald gestern habe ich halt dann mal selber eine
statistiken in die tabelle eingebaut also in meinem landkreis ranking tabelle das heißt man hat jetzt auch vier werte
vier spalten in der tabelle für ja landkreise bundesländer oder deutschlandweit
wo dann sagen der der mittelwert der median die standardabweichungen und die anzahl der fälle
auf der diese statistik basiert sodass man auch sehen kann wie wie viele fälle sind jetzt eigentlich eingegangen.
Kannst du das mal kurz erläutern und das sind ja so statistische begriffe.
Ich mein mein mathe verständnis ist da auch leider mangelhaft also was was heißt das erstmal es geht um die melde verzögerung also wie.
Spät landet das beim gesundheitsamt oder wie wie spät es ist die veröffentlichung beim die wir jetzt mein.
Es gibt in dem in den datensätzen gibt es ein sogenanntes meldedaten das ist das datum wann sich jemand
ans gesundheitsamt gewandt hat oder vom gesundheitsamt,
kontaktiert wurde wie auch immer aber typischerweise denke ich gehen die leute hin oder beziehungsweise ein arzt geht zum arzt und der meldet es dann den fall weil es ja meldepflichtig ist so also das meldet datum ist sagen wann
schlägt der fall beim gesundheitsamt auf so und dann gibt es das.
Veröffentlichungsparty datum was leider in den daten nicht drin steht deswegen brauchen wir halt die ganzen daten doms damit man sehen kann wann so ein fall das erste mal in so einem datenbank auftaucht
daraus sagen also wann ist jemand beim gesundheitsamt und wann ist die meldung beim l k i.
Und wird dann veröffentlicht also dort sagen in der zentralen statistik.
Und wie viele tage vergehen dazwischen und genau dann wird dann wird der fall gezählt so in der offiziellen statistik.
Das ist sagen die die verzögerung in tagen so
und was dazwischen passiert ist halt dass dann in der regel einen test veranlasst wird und dann wird das testergebnis abgewartet und wenn das testergebnis da ist erfolgt dann die meldung.
Und das erstaunliche ist dass es da wirklich sehr sehr große.
Unterschiede gibt wenn man sich die zahlen anguckt und jetzt zu den vier werten die ich da.
Angegeben habe das eine ist der mittelwert das ist einfach prinzip alle meldet verzögerungen aufaddiert geteilt durch die anzahl der meldungen.
Das ist dann die meldet verzögerung und die.
Variieren sagt sehr sehr stark also in berlin ist das mittel drei tage bremen.
Der schnellste landkreis mit zwei komma drei tagen im mittel und ja baden-württemberg braucht noch erstaunlich lange da sind es fünfzehn komma vier tage,
im mittel und ganz krass hamburg da will ich nochmal gleich extra eingehen sind zwanzig tage der mittelwert.
So
wer mittelwert kann aber natürlich durch einige wenige ausreißer doch sehr stark nach oben getrieben werden und deswegen hilft es sich halt den sogenannten median anzuschauen das ist.
Im prinzip der wert wo die hälfte aller meldungen
größer ist und die andere hälfte der meldungen also der wilde verzögerung kleiner ist es heißt man kann dann ungefähr sehen nach wie viel tagen habe ich die hälfte der meldungen eigentlich
bekommen und in den meisten ländern
liegt der media median zwischen null und zwei eigentlich ins
praktisch allen das heißt auch wenn ich in auch im saarland zwölf komma sechs tage habe im durchschnitt oder in baden-württemberg fünfzehn komma vier tage im in baden-württemberg
liegt der milliarden bei zwei tagen das heißt nach zwei tagen ist aber trotzdem schon die hälfte der fälle da nur die andere hälfte offensichtlich kann
echt lange dauern und zwar so lange dass sie den durchschnitt auf fünfzehn komma vier hochbringt,
und dann ist,
noch als weiterer wert die standardabweichungen angegeben die standardabweichungen ist wiederum
der durchschnitt der abweichungen vom mittelwert so also ja so vorstellen wenn alle verzögerungen gleich wären wenn es also.
Immer drei tage dauert dann wäre die standardabweichungen null weil.
Wenn das aber wild verteilt ist von nach meinem minus dreißig bis plus dreißig denn habe ich halt
eine standardabweichungen von zwanzig dreißig oder vierzig so das heißt es ist die standardabweichungen ist ein maß dafür wie wie groß die ausreißer sind im durchschnitt.
Also wie.
Wie flattern ist das.
Wie wie flattern ist es genau wie wie nahe sind die gruppiert um den durchschnitt oder wie stark weichen die halt vom vom durchschnitt ab.
Und da kann man sagen sie ist teilweise doch.
Die standardabweichungen ist recht hoch das heißt wir haben's also zwischen sieben und zwanzig beträgt die was halt bedeutet dass es,
in allen bundesländern fälle gibt die.
Sehr sehr lange dauern es ist zwar nicht nicht die meisten fälle aber es gibt.
Offenbar einzelfälle die irgendwie problemfälle sind und die aus irgendwelchen gründen
e verzögert sind ich habe teilweise ja schon gesehen dass manchmal ein schwung daten ankommt nach zwei oder drei monaten
kommen plötzlich fälle an und sowas treibt natürlich dann den den durchschnitt in die höhe.
Was wir aber jetzt im fall von hamburg,
haben ist nicht nur dass wir einen mittelwert von zwanzig haben was,
theoretisch durch eine handvoll fälle auch die irgendwo wiedergefunden in die in der kiste gefunden wurden und könnte das halt kommen nein wir haben auch einen median von fünfzehn tagen.
Das heißt nach fünfzehn tagen fehlt immer noch die hälfte,
aller meldungen und das wo alle anderen null ein oder zwei haben und zwei
ist tatsächlich schon nur bei baden-württemberg der fall also bei allen anderen ländern liegt der median bei null oder bei eins.
Oder anders ausgedrückt an dem tag oder einen tag später ist die hälfte der fälle gemeldet.
Genau so ist das zu lesen ja und in hamburg ist dauert es fünfzehn tage bis die hälfte der fälle irgendwie,
zusammen sind und das ist ja also so gesagt so unfähig können die hamburger eigentlich gar nicht sein,
das ist denke ich ein systematisches problem und,
könnte sogar den verdacht dass normalerweise manchmal razer.
So dass man irgendwie nicht keine bösartigkeit unterstellen sollte wenn unfähigkeit als erklärung für ein sachverhalt völlig ausreicht.
Aber in dem fall dass das das kann ich mir tatsächlich nicht anders erklären als.
Dass das systematisch so organisiert ist dass die zahlen.
E brauchen und erstmal rumliegen und weiß ich nicht und wozu das halt führt.
Da muss ich halt sehen wie ich damit jetzt umgehe ich hatte mich halt gewundert warum hamburg so viel besser dasteht als berlin.
Und der punkt ist ich hatte ja schon wegen dieser melde verzögerungen hatte ich ja schon die regeln gelockert,
also die beim die regel ist dass die sachen also ist die fälle
als in diese sieben tage fall grenze einzugehen also sieben tage grenze wurde ja von der bundesregierung wo er gesagt ok
wenn in den letzten sieben tagen mehr als fünfzig fälle
pro hunderttausend einwohner auftreten dann ist alarm.
Grenze wo jetzt auch reduziert weil die eigentlich hat mir auch schon ein freibad ist und und und viel zu hoch und bayern hat jetzt auch schon auf fünfunddreißig reduziert habe ich gelesen.
Aber das problem ist in diese sieben tage berechnung gehen halt nur die fälle ein.
Die in den letzten sieben tagen beim gemeldet wurden und wo weniger als sieben tage vergangen sind seit sich die person beim gesundheitsamt gemeldet hat.
Das heißt alles was länger als sieben tage braucht von.
Meldung beim gesundheitsamt bis zählung beim wird nicht gezählt als fall der letzten sieben tage sondern der der der schlüpft
halt durch so einfach bei diesem ding das geht dann zwar in die gesamtstadt ein das heißt die
gesamtzahl der fälle geht halt hoch aber ja es ist halt dann kein fall der letzten sieben tage mehr sondern es ist halt irgendwie ein altfälle was auf eine gewisse art und weise auch sinn macht,
alte fälle wegzulassen nur wenn dann wie gesagt im durchschnitt ist zwanzig tage dauert so
dann fällt es auch bei mir raus weil ich hatte sagen die die die die zählung dann auf vierzehn tage verlängert das heißt ich hab halt geguckt okay was ist in der letzten woche angekommen und habe aber,
lang meldet datum
vierzehn tage zurückliegend zugelassen um halt mehr fälle einzusammeln sozusagen da ein paar fälle noch.
Dann der aktuellen oder die letzten sieben tagen zugeschlagen so aber bei hamburg nützt selbst das nicht allzu viel weil sie sagt erst nach komischerweise ja fünfzehn tagen erst die hälfte der fälle da ist.
Deswegen ist wahrscheinlich das ranking von hamburg ist schlichtweg falsch in.
Bei einer tabelle ich weiß noch nicht wie ich damit,
umgehe ob ich da rückwirkend dann nochmal was drauf rechne wenn dann die,
die zahlen eintrudeln aber definitiv ist hamburg nicht so gut wie es hier im im im ranking erscheint während
bei allen anderen bundesländern teilweise hat mich das echt erstaunt wie viele also das viele bundesländer mittlerweile das.
Da echt auf draht sind also niedersachsen was glaube die hessen hessen schafft mittlerweile im im mittel in drei komma vier tagen zu melden so das ist sensationell weil oder,
sagt bremen sogar zwei komma drei thüringen ist auch recht fix dabei.
Mit zwei komma acht tagen wenn die werte siehst diese drei komma null bei in berlin im schnitt vier tage in nordrhein-westfalen und dann kommt hamburg zwanzig.
Und das ist einfach so wo ich wo ich erstmal dachte meine software ist kaputt.
Da ist irgendein fehler drin damit.
Das ist ja auch oft ein indikator dafür.
So aber dann bin ich zumindest dann bin ich halt reingegangen und habe mir die meldungen angeschaut und das sah erstmal plausibel
aus was meine software ich hab's noch nicht detail nachgerechnet aber ich habe da keinen offensichtlichen fehler gefunden und ich wüsste nicht warum er ausgerechnet für hamburg falsch rechnen sollte und für alle anderen landkreise plausible zahlen
auswirft und ja.
Also das ist etwas wo ich wirklich nicht mit gerechnet hatte und wo ich wirklich gespannt bin ob sich das irgendwann aufklärt oder ob es irgendeine erklärung dafür gibt was da in hamburg vor sich.
Aber das würde doch jetzt wieder dafür sprechen dass man doch hier für die berechnung der tabelle ein casting einführen muss also ein abgleich auf das tatsächliche erkrankung statue was wäre
prinzip bewusst weggelassen hast ums einfacher zu machen weil so die annahme na ja zwei wochen reicht ja eigentlich wollen wir nur auf eine woche blicken und dann haben wir noch eine ganze woche
dazu und bisher auch mit dem ganzen datenmaterial erst auf diese tabelle losgegangen nachdem man mal zwei wochen eingesammelt hat jetzt haben wir ja
auch den größeren blick zurück mit diesem anderen archiv wäre es ja durchaus eine möglichkeit die ganze tabelle anders aufzustellen und zu sagen okay wir
wenn man denn das jetzt normalisieren das vielleicht nicht das richtige wort also ein.
Haben wir ein gutes wort für dieses für dieses weg von den meldet zahlen hin zu den erkrankungen daten wie würdest du das nennen.
Ja letztlich ist es eine vorhersage der noch zu erwartenden.
Meldungen so das heißt wenn man weiß dass am ersten tag nur drei prozent der meldungen eingehen denn muss man halt irgendwie siebenundneunzig oder.
Nach einer woche bezahlten bestimmten korrekturfaktor drauf rechnen anhand aber dieser.
Doch sehr stark unterschiedlichen meldet verzögerungen was ich ich hätte gedacht die,
liegen eher irgendwo schwanken was weiß ich zwischen zehn und zwölf oder so das war meine vermutung.
Aber tatsächlich jetzt mit der mit der statistik stimmen die meisten annahmen.
Nicht mehr und ich weiß jetzt nicht wie das robert-koch-institut sein now casting.
Tatsächlich gemacht hat aber ich nehme mal sehr stark an dass die die verteilung auf bundesebene
genommen haben das heißt dass sie die sagen die zahlen für den bund genommen haben und die dann um die zahlen mit mit der statistik für die gesamten bunt korrigiert haben was.
Aber völlig falsche ergebnisse liefert wenn jetzt sich.
Zum einen die sachen in.
Verschiedenen bundesländern anders entwickeln und diese bundesländer dann auch noch eine sehr unterschiedliche melde verzögerung
ja dann kannst du eigentlich dein casting auch in die tonne kloppen oder zumindest wesentlich größeren fehler noch ausweisen
und dann bist du wahrscheinlich wenn du das machen würdest und auf bundesebene den fehler ausweist dann kommst du wahrscheinlich auch so eine aussage wie ok r liegt mit neunzigprozentigen wahrscheinlichkeit zwischen null komma fünf und eins komma fünf
dafür muss ich aber nicht rechnen so.
Also im prinzip müsste man das pro landkreis machen man müsste sich jetzt eigentlich jeden landkreis einzeln anschauen und
ok wie kommen da die meldung rein was sind da die erkrankung daten die da tatsächlich drinstehen und dann sieht man ja
wie sich das dann eben quasi so in die vergangenheit rein verteilt dann haben wir immer ein drittel der meldung ungefähr die halt überhaupt gar kein erkrankungen datum haben oder ich glaube vierzig prozent
sind das hat auch nochmal bestätigt dann kann man für die halt nur annahmen machen wir wissen ja immer noch nicht warum da keine erkrankung daten drinstehen also es kann halt sein dass es sich dabei um
tomaten fälle handelt also leute die gar keine krankheit in dem sinne entwickelt haben aber die aus irgendwelchen gründen trotzdem getestet wurden und dann eben.
Ja virus nachweis haben und infektiös sind aber in dem sinne kein erkrankungen haben dafür fehlt halt einfach ein ein ein feld das das das
ausdrückt oder man sagt halt naja da ist aus irgendwelchen gründen das erkrankungsrisiko nicht,
kann nicht ermittelt worden als nicht zu genau angenommen worden ist man einträgt dass macht's halt irgendwie ein bisschen schwierig.
Also das hat auf jeden fall die daten über die symptome also das ist auf jeden fall etwas was erhoben wird,
aber nicht mit veröffentlicht so könnten die eigentlich einfach mit in die datensätze ohne großes problem wahrscheinlich mit reinpacken also das ist letztlich,
hat sich jemand entschieden ne sagen wir nicht verraten wir nicht behalten wir für uns so aber die zahlen hat das die hat nur die öffentlichkeit nicht also über die symptome jetzt so,
und ja und den grund warum der test veranlasst wurde würde ich mal vermuten ist dem l k i,
auch bekannt zum,
ist nur es ist halt nicht so leicht möglich dass mit den tatsächlichen tests zahlen wahrscheinlich zu korrelieren wobei es da jetzt auch eine änderung gab weil jetzt auch negative tests ans gemeldet werden sollen was ja bisher
auch nicht der fall war so dass wir da hoffentlich wenn es dann in die gänge kommt demnächst
ja ich ich hoffe dass es dass ich dann jemand beim robert koch institut mal hinsetzt und dann doch nochmal die,
daten lieferungen entsprechend ergänzt und überarbeitet die der öffentlichkeit und der presse zur verfügung gestellt werden.
Finde ich halt schon mal 'ne wichtige vertrauensbildende maßnahmen weil je länger ich auf die zahlen draufgucke je mehr ich darüber erfahre so umso.
Weniger vertrauenswürdig oder umso mehr problembehebungen sind diese zahlen und ich wundere mich halt immer wieder dass es halt eigentlich,
immer schlimmer wird mit den problemen mit den zahlen.
Also in diesem.
Artikel gibt es da noch ein paar interessante einzelzahnrestauration b wurden jetzt hier die gesundheitsämtern in landshut und in bochum genannt die mehr als zehn tage bräuchten.
Um was zu melden.
Im schnitt kann ich jetzt aus deinen zahlen nur so teilweise herauslesen warum sie da eher unauffällig aus landshut ist bei dir noch auffälliger
warendorf in nordrhein-westfalen mit drei tagen
jetzt weiß ich nicht ganz genau ob das bei denen in mittelwert ist oder wie sie auf diese zahl gekommen sind.
Also landshut springt schon also landshut.
Ist schon auch also fast hamburger verhältnisse so mit sechzehn komma zwei tagen im mittel,
na gut mit einem medialen von von vier also ist doch nicht so schlimm wie wie hamburg und,
es sind auch relativ wenig fälle so dreiundzwanzig und zwölf jeweils so auf auf der diese diese analyse dann.
Basiert insofern ja und was war das was war der andere.
Warendorf sei besonders.
Warendorf.
Ja gut aber du wirst natürlich jetzt auch nur welchen zeitraum aus also der meldung verzögerung wie weit blickt das denn jetzt zurück.
Nur die letzten vierzehn tage.
Nee nee nee nee das sind sozusagen seit beginn meiner datenerfassung also ziemlich ziemlich genau einen monat sagen das sind die verzögerungen aus dem letzten monat und eigentlich hatte ich auch geplant.
Die dann über die sagen auch nochmal über die zeit zu plotten um zu gucken welche ämter denn jetzt gelernt haben und sich verbessert haben und wo,
die schneller geworden sind und welche die irgendwie langsamer geworden sind oder die überlastet sind oder.
Was auch immer weil aber ich halte es für auf jeden fall sinnvoller.
Nicht bis zum anfang zurückzublicken weil da gab's halt die große welle und
da waren alle sagen erstmal für alle war das neue oder für viele war das neu insofern denke ich sagen den letzten monat zu betrachten ist einigermaßen fair ja.
Hatten sie zwei monate zeit dass sich das ein rüttelt,
ganz offensichtlich hat sich das aber nicht überall eingerüstet während es doch in ganz ganz vielen landkreisen und ländern
super fix geht jetzt also schneller als das am anfang vermutet wurde viel schneller.
Du kannst auch nochmal so ein richtig professionellen visualisieren gebrauchen oder.
Naja es ist dann auch immer die frage sagen erstmal
was will man eigentlich untersuchen oder was will man was will man letztlich sehen und ja grafiken kommen auch ich hatte ja mit visualisieren angefangen eigentlich,
aber irgendwann so.
Ja braucht es halt eine andere herangehensweise und vierhundert verschiedene grafen visuell jetzt drauf zugucken hilft jetzt auch nicht nicht nicht unbedingt so.
Für vierhundert landkreise sondern da will man erstmal so sagen eine vorauswahl da will man ein paar kennziffer idealerweise haben wir jetzt eine kennziffer gefunden die ganz gut zu funktionieren scheint
kriege ich auch ganz anschaulich finde nämlich mit dem risiko ranking.
Ich werde nicht in feature ausatmen ne aber wenn man jetzt einfach mal auf die zahlen hier drauf zeigt und dann halt eine kurven verlauf bekommt über die zeit für die jeweiligen landkreis dann kann man halt auch schnell feststellen ob das gerade ein aktuelles problem ist oder etwas was in der vergangenheit liegt.
Vielleicht nochmal um diesen artikel komplett zu zitieren oder zumindest soweit zu zitieren wie es angemessen ist gründe die das nennt warum es denn jetzt überhaupt zu diesen ganzen verzögerungen kommt.
Also verspätungen bei den tests verspätungen bei den meldungen und daten übermittlung hat man schon eingabefehler.
Klar kann immer mal passieren verspätungen in arztpraxen und oder in den laboren test kapazitäten die gegebenenfalls nicht vorhanden sind ist natürlich auch noch so eine sache und also am anfang war das wahrscheinlich zumindest ein problem.
Leute die generell zu spät zum arzt gehen also die zwar aufgefordert werden sich testen zu lassen aber das dann eben machen also das führt natürlich alles auch zu melden verzögerung
ganz klar aber wie gesagt wenn man halt die daten wann denn irgendwas dann mal entdeckt wurde et cetera erkrankung start und nach führt dann kann man zumindest im nachhinein das machen kann
dann gab es noch die unterscheidung dass zum manche länder halt mehr erkrankung starten
erfassen als andere also so sind in den datensätzen von mecklenburg-vorpommern achtzig prozent der meldung mit erkrankungen datum geführt in bayern nur sechzig prozent.
Was schon relativ deutlicher unterschied ist wo man jetzt nicht sagen kann.
Bayern wenn die leute nicht so nicht so krank kann man ja nicht gerade ablesen aus den daten vielleicht liegt der grund er mehr aktivität.
Aber es kann natürlich auch wieder es halt immer das schwierige so sagen man man guckt,
erst mal auf so 'ne zahl drauf und dann kann das aber natürlich sehr unterschiedliche ursachen,
haben auch eine mischung meistens ist es von von ursachen und es kann eben sagte in dem fall auch dass,
bundesgesundheitsministerium wo die wohl angefragt haben es kann auch sein dass in bayern einfach mehr getestet
wird oder nur noch etwas anderes testregion gefahren wird und sie deswegen mehr symptomlos er haben die sie testen das kann also auch.
Durchaus möglich sein hätten wir jetzt die daten mit dem datensatz über die symptome könnten wir dazu auch aussagen machen.
Haben wir halt nicht ne genau.
Haben wir nicht genau und da ist wieder ja das bundesgesundheitsministerium wieder geheimes regierungswillen.
Ja wir haben uns ja auch vor ein paar tagen nochmal drüber unterhalten am telefon was denn überhaupt noch so daten wären die jetzt vor allem in der nächsten zeit auch ganz wichtig werden die halt auch nicht drin sind.
Das ist natürlich vor allem diese problematik der cluster beziehungsweise dieses warum treten auf einmal so viele,
fälle auf na ja also wir hatten das ja jetzt sagt gottesdienst da in hessen restaurant in leer
wo irgendwie eine größere gruppe drinnen zusammen saß und sich ordentlich mit ariola sohlen beworfen hat und ganz viele leute auf einmal krank geworden sind es macht natürlich ein riesenunterschied,
ob man solche super event hat.
Oder ob eben so eine infektionsbad zahl breit verteilt ist über ein landkreis.
Das ist halt in den daten so nicht drin weil man eben nicht diese information hat wer war denn jetzt hier der index fall also wer war quasi der auslöser dieses lokalen ausbruchs und wer ist.
Sozusagen da da dran gewesen also vielleicht auch etwas schwierig darzustellen aber
das sind halt alles so so fälle die man eben gerne haben will weil gerade deine tabelle hat ja immer so dieses problem mit
du machst das du dick fett alles in rot wenn halt die zahlen auf einmal nach oben galoppieren weil's ja in der woche vorher ganz gut aussah nicht in der hasse genauso leer ich weiß nicht wie leer ist wahrscheinlich ein paar hundert plätze nach oben geschossen innerhalb dieser.
Woche einfach weil vorher war da alles tutti und dann kommt er halt so ein infizierte rein nimmt an dieser party teil auf einmal sind hundert leute krank
natürlich ist das im vergleich zu vorher dann eben extrem aber das heißt natürlich jetzt nicht dass auf einmal über einen aus friesland die alarm glocken läuten.
Ohnehin in so einem bevölkerungs abendland natürlich schwierig klar ich weiß die leute gehen ja auch wieder woanders hin und stecken auch wieder welche an ist nachvollziehbar trotzdem wäre es ganz interessant,
das mal auseinander halten zu können.
Wer auf jeden fall hilfreich wobei ich sagen muss dass auch die frage so der volatilität,
in der tabelle ich bin eigentlich ganz zufrieden damit was ich halt also wenn wir jeden tag neue
zehn neue top ten hätten so dann hätte das verfahren glaube ich ein problem aber was wir halt schon haben oder sehen können ist dass es eine gewisse beharrlichkeit gibt
an einem bestimmten,
platz so zu bleiben und dann gibt's eben manchmal so diese sprünge in der regel natürlich nach oben so,
und dann sinken die fälle langsam ab komme ich da bringst du mich auf eine interessante idee ich glaube ich mache mal eine ich mache mal eine schicke visualisierung.
Davon wie die einzelnen kreise so quasi auf und ab hüpfen und wie sie so sich sagen so
mäßig so dann hoch katapultiert werden und dann vielleicht wieder langsam nach unten sinken das könnte glaube ich ganz hübsch.
Aussehen.
Ja da kann man gut von der bundesliga lernen das sind solche vergleichstabelle auch mal ganz interessant ne wenn man so sieht wie einzelne mannschaften über die zeit sich so durch die tabelle bewegt haben kann man dann so eine gewisse form schwäche erkennen.
Ja aber insgesamt jedenfalls finde ich so wie sich die tabelle verhält wie sich das ranking verhält eigentlich ganz ganz angenehm weil wie gesagt.
Es gibt halt so ein bisschen grundbewegung und dann aber
bestimmte fälle eben plötzlich raus und da kann sich ja fragen okay was ist denn da los was ist denn da passiert und meistens wird man dann auch fündig und findet dann in dem zusammenhang irgendwas im.
Internet sich irgendein heim irgendeine schlachterei irgendwelche erntearbeiter irgendwelche.
Sie bewerber heime oder andere unterkünfte oder soziale brennpunkte oder so ja
krankenhäuser genau aber sagt da muss man halt dann auch immer vorsichtig sein da haben wir jetzt weil.
Sagen okay das war jetzt alles beschränkt nur halt auf einem bestimmtes heim oder auf eine bestimmte gruppe da da das bestätigt sich nicht,
in allen fällen so das wollte ich auch mal gerne ein bisschen.
Zahlen unterlegen und auswerten.
Weil wenn dem so wäre dann müsste halt einen kreis hochspringen und dann innerhalb von vierzehn tagen aber eigentlich wieder dort sein wo er am anfang,
mal wahr oder von wo also wo er vor dem ausbruch gewesen ist,
aber ich habe das gefühl dass ich mehr landkreise gesehen hab die wenn sie einmal nach oben geschossen sind da eigentlich etwas länger geblieben sind als man jetzt.
Es annehmen könnte wenn das einfach nur so ein ausbruch war der ja.
Schnell isoliert wurde ja.
Nur der isoliert wurde und das kann man natürlich aus dieser aus dem ranking auch ganz schön dann dann heraus lesen was denn das tatsächlich die tatsächliche natur.
Des des ausbruchs ist.
Gut um das vielleicht abzuschließen den artikel habe ich dann auch noch die information entnommen dass wohl eine elektronische melde kette vom schon länger geplant ist tatsächlich läuft das schon seit anfang zwanzig sechzehn und sollte
unter dem schönen klingenden namen dem ist deutsches elektronisches milde und informationssystem für den infektionsschutz bis ende zwanzig abgeschlossen sein.
Also ich habe da keinerlei informationen darüber wie weit sie denn jetzt gekommen sind nach vier jahren nach,
unsere türkischen erfahrungen mit solchen großprojekten auf bundesebene kann man vielleicht sagen okay das,
weiß ich nicht ob das projekt jetzt unbedingt beschleunigung erfahren hat oder in welchem zustand ist sich gerade befindet aber offensichtlich ist es noch nicht komplett in place.
Gibt es aber wohl du hast ja auch noch eine weitere kleine änderung noch in deiner tabelle gemacht es gibt keine daten jetzt auch als csv zum,
download.
Also es gibt da zwei zwei c s v dateien einmal der inhalt der tabelle.
So wie er dargestellt wird so dass es die die eine tabelle und dann habe ich.
Auch nochmal die sagen meine angereicherten ursprungs also was ich halt mache ist dass ich diese gesamten dampf des letzten monats einen nach dem anderen durchgehe
und dann gucke welche neuen datensätze sind eigentlich dazugekommen und die neuen datensätze dann an den ersten datensatz anhänge
und gleichzeitig mit zeit stempeln versehen und noch ein paar berechnungen mache das datum irgendwie handhabbarer
mache also aus das datum sonst ist irgendwie in millisekunden
seit dem ersten ersten neunzehnhundertsiebzig das ist natürlich nicht so richtig
erstmal handhabbar ich rechne das halt einfach in tage um relativ zu einem tag null den ich gesetzt habe,
da kann man dann finde ich so tag neunundsiebzig ist halt angenehmer als so sechsundvierzig millionen zweihundertachtundsechzigtausend
so jetzt so einfach nur beim beim anschauen der der rohdaten was man auch manchmal gerne tun möchte so.
Das heißt ich rechne intern eben immer mit daten und außerdem reichere ich die noch um die einwohnerzahl der landkreise mit andi da auch.
Nicht mit drin steht in den daten sodass man relativ einfach die fälle je hunderttausend berechnen kann.
Was ich aber dazu sagen muss ist es gibt in meiner sagen angereicherten tabelle.
Und den sagen neun tabellen die ja alle fälle.
Eigentlich enthalten gibt es halt gewisse diskrepanzen also es geht nicht hundertprozentig auf was aber wiederum damit zu tun hat dass halt von einem tag auf den anderen.
Fälle verschwinden aus den neuen dampf die ich aber natürlich noch drin habe weil ich natürlich nur neue fälle hinzunehme.
Und ich versuche zwar auch rauszufinden welche dann also verschwunden sind und das zu kompensieren aber das geht halt alles nicht hundertprozentig auf so aber
ich sag mal das ist angesichts der.
Schwankungen oder anderen probleme mit den daten des geringste problem aber ganz offensichtlich hat mir schon.
Ist es so dass als ob jeden tag irgendjemand in die daten reingehen würde und.
Wild dinge ändert bis hin zum erkrankungen datum und zum melde datum und solche dinge.
Alter alles also und dann und da ist aber keine record gibt also dass das keine also da,
das jetzt keine individuellen fälle gibt keine möglichkeit des zuzuordnen kann man es halt nur über die daten zu.
Ordnen und zu gucken ja.
Ist das jetzt ok selber erkrankung tag selber meldet haag gleiches alter
gleiches geschlecht gleicher landkreis das muss derselbe datensatz sein ja oder derselbe dieselbe fall
zählung aber das schlägt natürlich in dem moment fern fehl wenn sich plötzlich das geschlecht der person ändert dann ist das so das habe ich dann.
Jetzt nicht auf dem schirm oder das kriege ich dann nicht kompensiert.
Auf jeden fall falls jemand lust hat mit deinen ausgerechneten daten zu arbeiten oder auch einfach nur so mit den finalen tabellen- daten und da paar andere anzeige konzepte auszuprobieren oder so dann,
wenn man das natürlich gerne sehen.
So dann schauen wir doch mal auf die öffentliche diskussion da hat ja bodo ramelow der ministerpräsident von thüringen bisschen welle gemacht denn er hat sich da auf die hinterbeine gestellt und hat gesagt also in unserem land.
Da geht das ja so richtig gut alles gerade.
Da könnte er den leuten ja nicht mehr vermitteln warum es überhaupt noch einschränkungen geben sollte und hat gefordert dass und oder halb angekündigt dass er.
Mitte juli glaube ich die restriktion aufheben möchte also bis hin zu masken tragen und so weiter soll alles nicht mehr sein.
Denn es wäre ja auch nicht zu vermitteln dass in thüringen wo es ja so super läuft.
Wo in der hälfte der landkreise das war glaube ich jetzt ich hoffe ich zitiere ihn da richtig in der hälfte der landkreise ja seit.
Seit drei wochen keine fälle mehr aufgetreten sind dass man jetzt hier noch irgendwie irgendwelche maßnahmen einhalten sollte und da dachte ich mir so.
Drei wochen also ein bisschen in die tabelle reingeguckt hier in unsere risiko tabelle hat mir so.
Welche zahlen hat er jetzt eigentlich gerade auf dem tisch.
Ja das hat mich auch so ein bisschen auf die palme getrieben und bin nämlich über über den podcast drauf gestoßen und da hatte er,
das mehrfach bei verschiedenen gelegenheiten gesagt also es scheint so eine leine gewesen zu sein die er offensichtlich nicht bei einer gelegenheit sondern die er halt.
Häufiger so von sich gegeben hat so und ja das ist einfach falsch und,
es ist nicht nur falsch sondern ich halte das auch für gelogen ist zwar jetzt ein hartes wort er könnte natürlich auch einfach falsch informiert.
Sein einfach bei seinen von seinen wem auch immer aber ich kann's mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen.
Also ich blicke jetzt mal kurz aktuelle datensatz heute achtundzwanzigster
mai und wir hatten ja schon gesagt thüringen hat durchaus ein paar contender im spiel sonneberg greiz gera gotha die sind alle relativ weit vorne weit gerade gotha wartburg
kreis auch gerade richtig schön nach vorne gegangen jetzt hast du ja auch glaube ich noch,
haben wir noch gar nicht gesagt du hast ja auch zwei felder eingeführt wann die letzte meldung ist also das war schon ein bisschen glaube ich letzte woche schon drin und die letzte zählung.
Das heißt man kann jetzt die tabelle auch immer ansehen also wann vor wieviel tagen hat das hat ein.
Oder das gesundheitsamt in einem landkreis das letzte mal eine meldung gebracht beziehungsweise wann wurde diese meldung das letzte mal vom veröffentlicht das heißt dann letzte zählung bei dir.
Also letztlich sie veröffentlichen halt im prinzip um mitternacht so
so dass man sagen kann dass es eigentlich der tag des meldung eingangs also wann ist sozusagen man ist das letzte mal was gekommen genau und die letzte meldung ist dann
wie weit liegt der fall zurück beim beim gesundheitsamt da kann man jetzt sagen beides ausschließen weil es hätte ja wenn wenn es weit zurückliegt könnte das immer irgendwie zwei ursachen haben können also vorher hatte ich immer nur sagen das melde datum
mit drin und nicht dass das ziel datum und jetzt hat man beides.
Also thüringen hat dreiundzwanzig landkreise und seine behauptung seit drei wochen wäre er da nicht mehr gemeldet worden.
Bei der hälfte der landkreise das trifft genau auf einen einzigen zu auf sommerda.
Wo seit sechsundzwanzig tagen nur tumble ist und danach weimarer land hat vor zwei wochen oder fünfzehn tagen letzte fall gemeldet ähnliches ist in jena.
Dreizehn tage.
Und in der tat sind es an sich ganz gute zahlen so in der unteren hälfte aber es halt mit nichten so dass jetzt schon so lange da nichts mehr passiert sei.
Definitiv das kann man so sagen da ist also die hälfte der landkreise kann man.
Sagen.
Steht ganz ganz gut da nochmal einen viertel wo man sagen okay berliner verhältnisse so ungefähr und,
dann ja haben wir da oben so sechs landkreise wo man sagen kann.
Die haben ein problem da sind.
Doch signifikant fälle dazugekommen so jetzt keine gigantischen mengen so.
Aber insbesondere ich mein sonneberg liegt halt.
Immer noch bei jetzt vierundvierzig komma fünf fällen je hunderttausend das ist jetzt knapp unter der fünfziger grenze gestern waren sie noch glaube ich über der fünfziger grenze,
ja und zwei andere auch mit dreißig und vierundzwanzig jeweils also gereizt und,
gera so da würde ich mich auch nicht wohlfühlen und tatsächlich in meinem
wäre jetzt meinem motorradclubs jetzt die pfingsttag gewesen am wochenende
irgendjemand ist oft die idee gekommen so nach thüringen zu fahren genauer gesagt nach suhl
sollte es gehen und ja nachdem ich dann so mal auf meine tabelle geschaut habe habe ich mich einfach entschieden doch dieses jahr
die pfingstferien den pfingsttag ausflug nicht stattfinden zu lassen.
Das muss das muss jetzt nicht,
es ist zwar ja mit den üblichen schutzmaßnahmen und so aber je nachdem wie man dann wo untergebracht ist und so also es war mir einfach ne,
muss nicht sein in einem monat vielleicht ist es dann kann man's immer noch nachholen muss jetzt nicht umfing sein.
Ja was machen wir jetzt da raus also das ist die diskussion was man jetzt überhaupt tun kann und und und sollte es natürlich schwierig.
Also grundsätzlich sage ich mal ist der ansatz ja nicht verkehrt zu sagen,
wir haben jetzt so unterschiedliche situationen in verschiedenen,
gegenden des landes da macht es keinen sinn wenn leute mit maske rumlaufen im landkreis wo es wirklich seit vier wochen keinen fall bekannt geworden ist so oder.
Aber das problem,
ist natürlich dass es dann schon sehr klare vorgaben von oben braucht weil wenn man einfach nur sagt auch ihr landkreise entscheidet einfach mal selber nach lust und laune,
so wie ihr die situation bei euch einschätzt und dann ja könnt ihr machen was ihr wollt dann ist natürlich der druck oder die versuchung,
so vor ort sehr groß auch unter umständen in richtung lockerung zu gehen das heißt.
Ohne halt klare vorgaben so ab.
Den und den fallzahlen wenn so ein bisschen wie die berliner ampel wobei die halt auch ja nicht toll ist so mittlerweile.
Aber sowas in der art brauchst dann eigentlich schon und dann haben wir natürlich das problem.
Vom anfang mit dass die zahlen eigentlich nicht toll sind das ja eigentlich.
Gerade dieses mit den lockerungen halt ganz ganz schwierig auch zu begründen ist wenn.
Die zahlen halt so spät kommen und so schlecht sind und wir dann auch natürlich gefahr laufen dass wir erst viel zu spät dann einen ausbruch mitbekommen in der schon wieder außer kontrolle ist wenn.
Es so lange braucht bis die zahlen an die öffentlichkeit gelangen und die leute reagieren können weil es ist ja kein spaß,
mit diesem
zahlen die sind ja auch wichtig sie sind ja auch wichtig damit die leute wissen wie sie sich irgendwo verhalten sollen und wenn die zahlen falsch sind oder zu spät kommen so dann bringt das halt effektiv leute in gefahr.
Au
das ist halt das das ding und nicht dann habe ich das gefühl dass ist noch nicht so in alle köpfe vorgedrungen die denken na ja das sind irgendwelche das sind halt zahlen das sind halt irgendwelche statistiken,
aber das ist halt die grundlage auch für politische entscheidungen wie aber auch individuelle entscheidungen so ob ich jetzt irgendwohin fahre oder nicht oder wie ich mich verhalte oder nicht und,
vor dem hintergrund ja macht mich das echt rasend dieser fahrlässige umgang mit den mit den zahlen in in vielen gegenden und,
muss auch sagen also es gibt da einfach kreise da fluppt das.
Da ist am ersten tag die hälfte aller fälle.
Getestet und gemeldet am abend ja da kommen die leute hin werden getestet und dann geht die meldung raus so beim und dann werden die gezählt am selben tag wo sie am gesundheitsamt auflaufen und dann gibt's halt,
eben hamburg.
Die hamburg.
Also zu türingen kann man sagen thüringen.
Gehört mit sicherheit nicht zu den ländern die gerade über lockerungen nachdenken oder großräschen sollten so das kann man einfach mal.
Festhalten also wenn,
dann jedes andere land außer bayern vielleicht so wir würde ich das dass das das abnehmen aber ihr einmal ja mecklenburg-vorpommern so zum beispiel da
also wenn ein land dazu berufen wäre über lockerungen zu reden denn mecklenburg-vorpommern.
Gut dann um das mal abzuschließen hier mit den ganzen zahlen.
Was mir noch so aufgefallen ist in der ganzen sonstigen debatte mit was was könnte denn jetzt noch auf uns zukommen und wie wie können wir denn damit umgehen und und und was haben wir denn noch vielleicht interessantes gelernt also erstmal hatte ich zu den eindruck.
Es kam in letzter zeit deutlicher hervor.
Dass man eigentlich sieht die probleme der ansteckung finden in innenräumen statt.
Also letzte zeit weiß nicht ganz genau es gehört habe war das glaube ich vom trosten oder so oder doch.
Alle haben davon.
Also alle haben eigentlich darüber geredet und so so grob habe ich so faktor fünfzehn bis zwanzig ist es so glaube ich das was so allgemein sich abzeichnet je nachdem wie man fragt und wie die zahlen interpretiert werden also.
Knapp zwanzig mal so viele fälle infektionen finden in innenräumen statt als draußen.
Woraus ich ableiten kann also erstmal hat mir ja das auch schon relativ früh glaube ich diese ariola sohl diskussion bei uns.
Von neun wochen am.
Ja
Anfang april anfang ab
genau lagen wir da ja doch ganz ganz richtig was so die vermutung angeht und wo wir.
Sagt haben ja unter bestimmten bedingungen wird es halt erborgene ich meine das war auch damals als wir das.
In der sendung erwähnt hatten auch schon stand der wissenschaft dass verbreitung über euro sohle.
Stattfindet und wir haben ja auch die beispiele gebracht so mit club trompete und dem
chor in den in den usa und ja aber dann braucht es wohl noch mal acht wochen und nochmal irgendwie weitere gottesdienste mit,
gesang und ja weitere partys in innenräumen als wenn man irgendwie sich es jetzt vergessen hätte nach acht wochen um das wieder ins bewusstsein zurück zu.
Ja gut ich meine anekdotischen evidenz versus studie die das belegen also das ist
zumindest ist es jetzt klar also es ist klar dass es so ist und ich empfinde das jetzt grundsätzlich auch erstmal als eine sehr beruhigende information weil es nämlich einfach bedeutet,
man kann sich jetzt draußen einfach auch mal treffen es ist irgendwie kein problem im garten rumzusitzen und auch mal ein bisschen besucher zu haben und da kann man dann glaube ich auch so vorgaben mit so und so viele haushalte dürfen daran beteiligt sein
ein bisschen entspannter sehen.
Was ich sagen wollte was sich verändert hat
gegenüber damals vor acht wochen ist dass man jetzt davon ausgeht dass eine wesentlich größere zahl an übertragungen stattfindet dass die euro sohle eine wesentlich größere rolle spielen als man damals so noch
vermutet hatte so dass es da gibt es jetzt auch ein paar mehr zahlen zu.
Also das bedeutet natürlich wenn man jetzt mal raus ableitet was.
Was könnte man denn jetzt zulassen also es gibt ja schon so diesen trend oder auch schon die forderung und russland ist glaube ich auch gesagt so ja warum nutzen den restaurants jetzt nicht konsequenterweise das draußen also wenn man jetzt auch in den städten,
und gemeinden einfach auch mehr flächen bereitstellt gab es schon so ein paar vorstöße.
Glaube ich schon länger in dänemark und keine ahnung es pop jetzt überall so auf dass man halt parkplätze wegnimmt und stattdessen,
platz macht also da so eine kleine veranda hinbaut gibt glaube ich sogar städte die das dann
bauen und und und und und den restaurants vermieten oder irgendwie sowas oder sogar kostenlos bereitstellen dass man da halt einfach draußen plätze schafft auch für restaurants die halt sonst nicht genug haben oder
überhaupt gar keine haben.
Open-air veranstaltungen aller art denke ich kann man auch ein bisschen entspannter sehen wir werden zwar den festivalsommer trotzdem nicht bekommen weil der ist irgendwie durch das irgendwie alles abgesagt aber.
Ich sehe durchaus möglichkeiten dass man im juli oder im august solche kleineren veranstaltungen zumindest mal zulassen kann wenn die draußen stattfinden.
Einerseits andererseits bedeutet das natürlich auch dass es genau dann wieder oder da problematisch bleibt oder dann auch noch wird wenn's gegen den herbst zugeht.
Wo man eben drin ist also kneipen bass clubs.
Kirchen büros ich höre von vielen.
Leuten die so in so firmen arbeiten ich mache das ja nicht aber es findet statt das.
Erfreulich gute erfahrungen gemacht worden mit diesem ganzen homeoffice also diese zeit hat glaube ich da auch wirklich so ein paar blockaden gelöst.
Immer so diese widerstände gibt so die leute ne wenn die leute nicht zur arbeit kommen und so dann arbeiten die ja gar nicht in bonn den ganzen tag in der nase und und dann und dann läuft ja hier nix mehr und jetzt waren sie alle gezwungen alle nach hause zu schicken.
Um festzustellen so schlimm war es dann doch nicht.
Und teilweise einfach dann auch regelungen aufgebrochen wurden so nach dem motto du wenn du mal ein,
einmal in der woche oder einmal im monat homeoffice machen willst dann musst du jetzt nicht hier mit dem ärztlichen attest oder mit irgendwie der handwerker termin der sich nicht verschieben lässt etcetera machst du es halt einfach was soll's sparen wir uns der administrativen.
Und und und und läuft schon außerdem haben viele unternehmen jetzt entsprechende infrastrukturen.
Aufgebaut also zugänge übers internet muss ja auch alles sicher sein etcetera.
Zugriff von außen das denke ich mal müsste sogar noch ausgeweitet werden,
einfach um zum beispiel im herbst generell da vielleicht auch nochmal zurück fahren zu können ich war wieder ein großes ausbruch geschehen ist sondern um vielleicht auch einfach von vornherein zu verhindern.
Wobei es auch sagen muss es sind oft gar nicht oder nicht nur allein jetzt die arbeitgeber die jetzt vielleicht vorbehalte gegen homeoffice hatten es gibt.
Auch statistiken.
Über überstunden des auch also häufig ein grund dafür warum leute überstunden machen ist weil sie die zeit nicht zuhause verbringen wollen und so also.
Ja okay gut das mag sein.
So also ich denke es wird eine ganze reihe von leuten geben für die könnte home-office die hölle gewesen sei aber die die ersten waren die sich freiwillig gemeldet haben
die die stellung zu halten oder aus dem home-office zurückzukehren also auch denke auch diese fälle gibt es,
aber grundsätzlich denke ich ist es ganz gut diese zusätzliche flexibilität die da jetzt eingekehrt ist.
Was wir auf jeden fall brauchen sind natürlich auch eine ausweitung der tests da wird viel drüber diskutiert ich
bin mir nur immer noch nicht so sicher ob sich denn hier eigentlich schon irgendwas getan hat also die vorgabe des ist glaube ich immer noch das wesentliche leute getestet werden sollen
die symptome haben aber nicht unbedingt alle anderen und das verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt derzeit nicht so richtig.
Also,
sie fahren da immer noch diese ja versuchen so eine ganz feine linie zu fahren so zwischen jeder der will kriegt einen test das ist immer noch nicht so,
also offiziell nicht so faktisch ist es wahrscheinlich schon so dass wenn du einfach nur sagst so
ja mir geht's nicht so aber vielleicht wollen sie auch
einfach eine mittel in der hand behalten gegen die hypochonder oder gegen die leute die dann alle zwei tage ankommen und sich gerne testen lassen.
Wollen aber ansonsten ja soll schon,
irgendwie jeder getestet werden der irgendwie dann doch viel leicht.
Leichte symptome also weil die leute sollen ja lieber früher als später kommen also grunde genommen wir genügend
wenn du sagst ich habe einen kratzen im hals so müsste eigentlich jetzt nach definition des schon ausreichen damit du,
getestet oder sagen wir so ich habe ein leichtes kratzen im hals und,
so meine weiß ich frau arbeitet im krankenhaus so.
Das ist wahrscheinlich dennis wahrscheinlich schon das kriterium erfüllt oder ich bin verkäufer und
auch immer oder ich arbeite in einem restaurant und habe ein kratzen im hals dann kriegst du wahrscheinlich den test ganz ganz schnell,
aber so das mag natürlich auch regional sehr unterschiedlich sein und hängt wahrscheinlich auch vom arzt ab auf der anderen seite also ich weiß nicht so viele ärzte kenne ich jetzt nicht die wenn man da hinkommt,
und darauf besteht einen test zu haben die dann sagen nö du kriegst keinen gibt es wahrscheinlich auch aber.
Am anfang gab es das auf jeden fall also da gab's widerspruch ich kenne selber so ein fall
wo soldat wieso ist auch hier erkältungszeit und wo sagen wir mal das problem an sich auch noch nicht so wahr,
genommen wurde das ist natürlich mittlerweile nicht mehr so aber was mir jetzt generell fehlt sind halt einfach die nächsten schritte also was ist denn jetzt eigentlich die strategie
für so schnell tests anstatt dass man immer diesen aufwendigen pc kram machen kann einfach auch um größere gruppen selber mal so vor testen
zu können also soll ja angeblich verfügbar sein aber habe ich bisher noch nichts konkretes gehört.
Also sie sind offenbar immer noch am hochskalieren eigentlich gibt sie schon seit über einem monat sind die validiert und zugelassen und aus entwickelt so.
Ich glaube sogar seit sechs wochen und ich wundere mich auch langsam wo die dinger.
Bleiben weil eigentlich müssten die jetzt langsam mal auch in größerer zahl verfügbar sein so und tatsächlich.
Halte ich es auch für nicht sinnvoll jetzt die gängigen c tests die ja so hundertzwanzig bis hundertvierzig euro das stück kosten,
gibt es auch riesige preisspanne ich glaube so ja zwischen hundertzwanzig und dreihundert euro je nachdem wo man da hingeht und
welches labor das macht die sind ja auch nicht standardisiert wobei es da mittlerweile also für kassenpatienten ja.
Ja da sind natürlich die die kassen haben wir es jetzt über geholfen gekriegt so,
auch die tests alle zu zahlen und die wehren sich ja gerade auch mit.
Vermutlich ja ganz guten erfolgsaussichten weil,
also speziell lang tests von leuten die keine symptome haben die sollen ja auch von den kranken oder müssen von den krankenkassen im moment auch mit,
bezahlt werden und das ist vermutlich
verfassungswidrig weil es ist immer ein großes wort so verfassungswidrig so ich gehe zur bundesverfassungsgericht
aber in dem fall ist es ist es schon so dass halt die mittel der beitragszahler einfach zweckgebunden sind
ja nicht für allgemeine gesundheitsvorsorge.
Eingesetzt werden dürfen so ohne weiteres und.
Insofern glaube ich wird wird es noch ein längeres politisches nachspiel haben und irgendwann wird wahrscheinlich irgendein verfassungsgericht kann ich das bundesverfassungsgericht wird wahrscheinlich darüber urteilen ob
dann die kassen vom bund geld.
Kriegen für einen teil der tests die sie jetzt verdonnert worden sind zu bezahlen aber eigentlich der meinung sind dass sie sie nicht bezahlen.
Müssen oder gar nicht bezahlen dürfen so ein bisschen die kontroverse.
Also ich war ja auch schon ganz froh wenn es ein antikörper test problemlos gäbe ich weiß nicht also davon was gehört ob das durchführbar ist so ohne weiteres.
Wer grundsätzlich meine senator flowtest sollten halt auch verfügbar sein problem ist natürlich dass jetzt auf der welt,
eigentlich eine bedarf nach milliarden dieser diversen tests gerade
da ist und irgendwie scheinen wir bei uns nicht so zu den bevorzugten ländern zu gehören wo jetzt allzu viel
bekannt ist darüber wahrscheinlich müsste man in die apotheke gehen und mal mal mal nachhören.
Ja ich meine jetzt gar nicht diese leckere flotte mata diese diese diese streifen wo man das sozusagen einfach so wie so ein schwangerschaftsthema an sich selber ausführen kann nee es gibt ja auch die möglichkeit sich richtig im blut auf antikörper testen zu lassen.
Ja ja.
Soliden test ich weiß aber nicht ob das also ich habe gehört dass man das machen kann und dass man das selber bezahlen muss und fall.
Aber ich habe da ein bisschen unkenntnis darüber aber ich würde es ehrlich gesagt ganz gerne mal machen wollen.
Einfach mal um zu wissen ob man nicht vielleicht schon zufällig irgendwie durchmarschiert ist und zu den symptomlos er gehört hat sein.
Es ist auf jeden fall eine interessante idee ich werd mich da auch mal schlau machen wie situation hier vor ort aussieht und wenn du was erfährst kann man dann in der nächsten sendung dann vielleicht von berichten von unseren erfahrungen,
zu versuchen ein.
Antikörper test zu kriegen falls jemand da informationen hat wir sind dafür alles empfänglich dann noch ein kurzer hinweis gibt eine interessante studie die liegt nahe dass.
Vitamin d unter umständen eine größere rolle darin spielen kann wie gut man gewappnet ist gegen einen möglichen krankheitsverlauf.
So wie eine untersuchung aus irland und die legen so ein bisschen nahe dass die zahlen dafür sprechen dass überall dort wo viel vitamin d in den menschen ist.
Es zu einer geringeren sterblichkeit kommt und das vitamin d ist ja jetzt so dass bildet ja der körper selber in dem moment.
Wo man der sonne ausgesetzt ist und man würde halt denken so okay dann müsste es ja italien und spanien eigentlich besser gehen als anderen ländern aber die zahlen
sprechen halt genau dagegen sondern es ist wohl so dass in ländern wie kanada wien
wo halt generell vitamin-d-mangel vorherrscht oder es wahrscheinlicher ist dass er vorherrscht eben weil und nicht so viel sonne ist.
Über die nahrung gezielt vitamin d verteilt wird so wie man das ja hier auch mit jod und floor macht salz cetera,
und dass damit die menschen sehr viel besser im saft stehen was vitamin d betrifft und dass das eben auch eine positive wirkung gehabt hat und das länder die es nicht machen unter anderem auch dann entsprechend schlecht dastehen.
So mal schauen weitere sache und dann sind wir vielleicht ein bisschen möglichen maßnahmen und interessanten erkenntnissen dann auch mal durch.
Ist nämlich.
Diese frage wie kann man denn einen ausbruch vorhersagen und ich hatte das hier schon länger in meiner liste stehen es war ein artikel auf heise es gibt nämlich auch die möglichkeit die virus verbreitung über das abwasser.
Festzustellen und das bedeutet in den in den wasserwerken.
Wo im prinzip all das was wir so ausscheiden hingesprüht wird.
Dort tests auf die viruslast im abwasser zu machen um dann zu schauen.
Denn hier überhaupt in dieser region also nicht bei einzelnen haushalten und schon gar nicht bei einzelnen
leuten sondern eben in einer größeren region in einer in einer stadt oder in einem stadtteil je nachdem wie das mit dem wasserwerken dann so aufgeteilt ist und das hat wohl durchaus
interessante ergebnisse gebracht also man hat da so im februar schon mal geschaut und dann war da irgendwie noch gar nichts zu sehen und im märz im april hat sich das dann schon wieder.
Anders entwickelt das war jetzt glaube ich in den niederlanden wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Und tatsächlich konnte man also darüber auch vorhersagen wo denn ein ausbruch kommt weil man quasi im abwasser schon drei vier tage vorher gesehen hat.
Was ich dann später eben durch gemeldete neuen fiktion gezeigt hat dass hier eben sich das virus verbreitet also auch an der stelle ich weiß nicht was da in deutschland schon getan wird in diese richtung aber das könnte auf jeden fall.
Auch nochmal so ein mittel sein um früher reagieren zu können.
Bei mir jetzt gerade überlege wie lange das voll dauert sowas flächendeckend zu
organisieren dann willst du es natürlich möglichst flächendeckend haben aber es.
Der vielleicht gar nicht so verkehrt wenn es funktioniert ich habe die studie jetzt selber nicht nicht gelesen ich weiß nur es gibt da so eine expertentool die das schon seit einer ganzen weile machen und auch für,
alle möglichen anderen krankheiten und viren und sonstigen,
stoffe gemacht hat und gut die sind natürlich überzeugt von ihrer methode
insofern ja lohnt es sich aber glaube ich auf jeden fall da nochmal genauer draufzuschauen und
der vielleicht nicht verkehrt sind vom robert-koch-institut eigentlich sollte das überhaupt kein problem sein für die
mal hier proben zu entnehmen und auch zu analysieren ich denke mal dass die alles auch haben sollten was sie dafür brauchen und es ist auch nicht weit bis zu den abwässern.
Um da proben zu entnehmen also insofern.
Erstens ist es ein interessantes pooling zweitens weiß man eben auch sofort auf welchem bereich es sich bezieht also es ist macht dann relativ klare aussage weil man weiß ja bus herkommt.
Gut war dann mal zu digitalen fragen übergehen ich habe da noch ein paar sachen zusammengetragen.
Auf jeden fall.
Rund um die tracing apps so abgeht und gab insofern was interessantes als das vor ein paar tagen die schweizer.
Tracing app.
Also die natürlich auch auf dem google apple modell basiert nur wenige tage nach dem also eine woche nach dem apple und google jetzt ihre papis veröffentlicht haben.
Auch diese app das licht des tages gesehen hat die ist jetzt noch nicht im app store.
Aber es wurde eine public beta-release und ich habe dann über twitter relativ schnell davon wind bekommen und bevor das peter programm da voll war war ich in der lage mir mal die app runterzuladen.
Und ja das ist natürlich jetzt insofern erstmal interessant als dass ich ja dadurch,
überhaupt erst in der lage war diese bluetooth kommunikation auf meinem telefon einzuschalten vorher gab es zwar dieses feature im prinzip aber es ist halt gesperrt solange bis es eben auch eine passende app gibt die zugriff darauf haben darf.
Und im rahmen dieses bitter programms,
konnte halt diese app dann auch schon dieses privileg damit einbringen und so wurde dann mit dem staaten der app und einer entsprechenden,
nachfrage ob ich denn das jetzt hier mal aktivieren möchte wurde dann das tatsächlich bei mir freigeschaltet.
Die app selber ist jetzt nicht sonderlich überraschend die kommt also mit sehr viel infos greens daher und erklärt alles relativ ordentlich und fragt schön brav für die ganzen per missions auf die einzelnen dinge
insofern ja wenig überraschend aber auch jetzt nicht sonderlich enttäuschend.
Also das das war so wie es erwartet habe also man man installiert sich die app dann
kriegt man erst mal so ja was ist denn das ziel das und das
wollen wir jetzt hier machen wir wollen im virus einen schritt voraus sein aber hier werden preise sie bei design und alles ist total
anonym und wir benutzen bluetooth und so läuft das und nachdem das erklärt wird sagt man okay willst du das jetzt hier auch aktivieren passt alles schon
sie bleiben anonym dann als wird man
das und dann kommt halt so dieser standard dialog vom selbst jetzt auf dem iphone natürlich getestet kommt dann hoch und fragt halt so möchtest du dass neunzehn kontakt protokoll und die entsprechenden mitteilung
aktivieren also hat man sozusagen eine freischaltung für zwei funktionen gleichzeitig
und ja dann habe ich das eingeschaltet und dann wird dann noch so
das ein oder andere erzählt und angezeigt einfach nur dass das dressing eben jetzt aktiv ist und es ist noch keine meldung gibt dann habe ich mal geschaut wie sehen das jetzt eigentlich aussieht auf system ebene man kann ja dann in den
einstellungen unter diesen gesundheit settings
gucken so aha okay was ist denn das jetzt hier eigentlich und dann steht da so okay kontakt protokoll ist eingeschaltet und sagt mir halt.
Dein gerät macht halt jetzt zufälliger und nach vierzehn tagen wenn ihr auch wieder weggeschmissen.
Und die app dieses cover-up wird mir dann halt angezeigt als dass das die app ist die darauf zugreifen kann soweit alles wenig überraschend,
dann was ich aber ganz interessant finde ist das zumindest das iphone einem dann eben diese kontakte überprüfung die stattgefunden haben auch auflistet also immer wenn die app ein kiel aus dem netz holt und da rein pumpt.
Und so eine überprüfung stattfindet dann wird sie auch protokolliert man kann sich das sogar als als jason datei exportieren das schon extrem nerdig fand für.
Für apple verhältnisse das hat man normalerweise nicht.
Und ja soweit hat das alles funktioniert.
Ich gucke gerade mal was ich jetzt mittlerweile an kontakt überprüfung habe also mehr ist nicht passiert gab dann tag später nochmal vier also da läuft jetzt noch nicht so viel
es geht jetzt auch erst mal darum dass die app als solche getestet wird aber sie ist schmeißen gerade noch nicht viel da rein also warum auch immer ja.
Und dann habe ich mir das mal auf bluetooth ebene angeschaut ob denn das ding auch das tut was es soll und ja ich kann bestätigen also dem moment wo das angeschaltet war,
ich habe dann so einen bluetooth canna auf meinem auf dem anderen gerät gestartet mal so geguckt und
hat mir die jetzt nicht so bald für beide angeschaut aber ich habe zumindest dann eben gesehen aha okay hier ist ein,
ohne weitere angaben senden des device was relativ nah ist und regelmäßig nachrichten auspumpen dann habe ich mal die funktion ausgeschaltet und gleich wieder eingeschaltet und dann
merkte ich so ah okay das was ich vorher gesehen habe also die die ich da vorher gesehen habe die war.
Sozusagen oder die adresse die ich davor gesehen habe die die war dann nicht mehr da dafür tauchte eine andere auf also hat sich quasi seine adresse geändert und nach fünfzehn minuten passiert ja das eben auch automatisch also funktioniert so wie das.
Angekündigt waren.
Gut zu wissen.
Ja dann.
Weiß man jetzt von dieser corolla also der deutschen app dass sie erst im juni rauskommen soll.
Ob es da so ein paar blick peter programm gibt keine ahnung weiß ich nicht und ich habe mir auch vor allem überlegt es wäre ja ganz sinnvoll dass wenn sie jetzt so ein release date haben dass sie die nackte app ohne.
Benachrichtigungs funktion auch schon mal ausliefern können weil dadurch ja eben dieses dressing überhaupt erst eingeschaltet wird.
Und wenn man halt jetzt.
Was weiß ich eine woche oder zwei wochen vorher sagt sogar hier ist schon mal die app die erzählt dir was wir tun werden aber das dahinter läuft alles noch nicht ja also test sind jetzt noch nicht freigeschaltet und so weiter aber wir schalten schon mal ein und
können schon mal anfangen zu sammeln und bin dann losgeht dann.
Wird man zumindest schon mal notifiziert wenn jemand ein test gehabt hat das weiß ich nicht ob das getan werden wird ich.
Würde man sagen vom bauch herr wahrscheinlich eher nicht weil da noch genug zu tun ist aber noch werden wir sehen.
Ja und die ganze technische diskussion die jetzt so im hintergrund abläuft die dreht sich halt um das was ich letzte woche schon angesprochen habe nämlich um das roaming.
Und offensichtlich gibt es da jetzt einen.
Ein vorstoß von google und apple.
In dem bereich halt was zu machen das hatte ich glaube ich letzte woche auch schon mal grob skizziert.
Und es zeichnet sich da wohl so drei modelle ab.
Die so verglichen werden also wie denn das sozusagen jetzt eigentlich alles funktionieren kann das hat ja alles so seine vor und so seine nachteile.
Also um vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz das problem klar zu machen was grundsätzlich da ist.
Hätten wir jetzt nur eine app für die ganze welt ja dann gäbe es dieses problem nicht aber wir,
haben nicht eine app für die ganze welt sondern wir haben,
unterschiedliche regionen unterschiedlichen vorstellungen wie sowas zu laufen hat und vor allem eben mit einer unterschiedlichen infrastruktur,
testing infrastruktur gesundheitsämtern infrastruktur etcetera wir reden hier viel darüber wie es in deutschland ist manches mag in anderen ländern ähnlich sein aber es gibt einfach auch signifikante unterschiede die unterscheidung in länder ist halt einfach mal realität
man will aber jetzt insbesondere in europa natürlich.
Hier auch gerne in den genuss kommen auch gewarnt zu werden wenn halt jetzt leute die vielleicht normalerweise nicht in deutschland sind zu nahe kommen damit das eben auch länderübergreifend funktioniert
und ohne roaming also ohne verbindung der einzelnen länder natürlich eben genau dieses problem dann kommt halt irgendwie,
was ich der italiener zu besuch aber der italiener kriegt halt danach nicht gesagt dass er hier einer später getesteten positiv getesteten person ausgesetzt war weil einfach seine app selbst wenn sie die empfangen hat nicht davon kenntnis erhält.
Und das ist das problem was man lösen will in jede richtung.
Also im prinzip kann man ja drei fälle unterscheiden einen ausländer kommt nach deutschland ein deutscher.
Fährt ins ausland oder ja ich sage mal der italiener und der deutsche treffen sich in frankreich so die drei.
Genau das konferenzzentrum mario genau.
Ja genau die fälle will man ja irgendwie möglichst alle abdecken.
Wenn man wenn man sich das so anschaut was er gerade so vorgeschlagen wird an verschiedenen konzepten des das ist alles sehr verwirrend deswegen werde ich jetzt ja auch nicht
anfangen im einzelnen nochmal zu erklären was da jetzt diese modelle sind sein er was du die generellen probleme sind das generelle problem ist.
Baut man sich jetzt eine infrastruktur wo die länder miteinander einzeln.
Verträge abschließen und sich gegenseitig diese kies weiterleiten,
wenn ich jetzt dieses problem lösen will mit hier ist ein kiel und von dem kiel heißt es da war ich aber gerade in frankreich dann muss ich das an den französischen server schicken,
das heißt deutschland und frankreich abgesehen davon dass jetzt frankreich ein schlechtes beispiel ist weil die sich ja immer noch nicht zum dezentralen modell haben durchringen können wenn sie es wahrscheinlich irgendwann genötigt werden zu sein ja aber im prinzip musste müsste deutschland halt mit
jedem land in europa oder überhaupt mit jedem land in der welt eine vereinbarung treffen wie die die daten untereinander austauschen.
Was dann auch bedeutet mit.
Man muss sich da einige werden man muss da einzeln darüber reden man muss kompatibles protokoll sprechen.
Und das muss dann irgendwie auch am ende alles noch getestet werden und funktionieren so mit zwei ländern macht das ja noch gehen mit drei ländern.
Mag es vielleicht auch noch gehen.
Aber das ist ja dann so in mal in minus eins viele kombinationen von bilateralen abkommen.
Und man kann sich vorstellen dass das eigentlich unrealistisch ist es ist einfach,
der gedanke allein dass jetzt alle länder mit allen sich irgendeiner form auf dem datenaustausch einigen und dass das dann irgendwie auch noch funktionieren soll
das sehe ich irgendwie dich man man nennt das ja irgendwie sharing dass sie sozusagen dann die die kies immer das richtige land weiterleiten und das,
ist glaube ich dann doch eher unwahrscheinlich dass es zu so einer lösung kommen wird,
außerdem hast du so ein bisschen noch zu so einem so einem so ein preis die problem für die länder weil die ja dann quasi auch sehr detaillierte auskünfte darüber geben wie viele fälle sie da haben und so weiter
und deswegen macht es für mich so den eindruck als ob sich so auf internationaler
ebene dieses modell eines eines eines roaming servers durchsetzt der quasi von allen ländern das so gesteckt.
Und der dann eben von irgendeinem übergeordneten trusted buddy betrieben wird also man könnte sich vorstellen für die ganze welt dass zum beispiel die who so ein server betreibt.
Dann wäre das sozusagen immer noch so die andere quelle wo man so seine kies herholen kann
die von der anderen ländern rausgespuckt werden die jetzt quasi nicht in ihrem eigenen land stattgefunden haben ich meine es ist ja nun mal so dass die meisten leute sind die meiste zeit in ihrem eigenen land.
Das einfach so also wenn ihr nackten zahlen anschaust so damit kann man wahrscheinlich das schon zu fünfundneunzig prozent abfangen aber du willst ja auch die anderen fünf prozent haben.
Es gibt länder mit mehr durchlauf wegen tourismus etcetera businesskontakte all das und die willst aber natürlich auch noch mit ab.
Aber wenn jetzt alle sich mit allen irgendwie aber irgendwas einigen müssen und alle sollen allen irgendwelche daten schicken.
Dann sitzen wir hier noch irgendwie zehn jahre bis das thema irgendwie komplett durch ist wenn man aber so ein roaming server verwendet dann ist es so ein bisschen einfacher.
Weil man eigentlich nur sagt so aha okay du warst in einem anderen land dann schicken wir das mal an den roaming server weiter und der verteilt quasi den ganzen rest.
Und dann lässt sich das darüber regeln dass alle apps halt nicht nur den home befragen sein eben nebenbei auch noch den.
Roaming server mit hier ich war da und da und gibt mir mal irgendwie kies die jetzt hier relevant sind dann verteilt sich das auch auf eine interessante art und weise und man hat auch nur noch so einen einzigen trust ort nämlich.
Beim betreiber dieses servers dass da irgendwelche statistiken erhoben werden können welche länder denn jetzt hier wie viele diagnose fälle haben etcetera.
Was ja ohnehin in gewisser hinsicht eine öffentliche information ist oder zumindest sein sollte aber solche aspekte gibt es sicherlich auch noch.
Ich vermute mal dass es noch eine weile dauern wird bis dieser roaming server so das licht des tages sieht also ich weiß es nicht so ganz genau ich habe so den eindruck.
Dass da ampel und google an irgendwas bauen und wie ich.
Die verteilung zwischen diesen beiden unternehmen mir auch so vorstellen kann baut da wahrscheinlich google da dran das ist echte totale vermutung von mir aber wieso backend das können die halt auch sprich wenn die.
Als open source lösung so ein roaming server rausbringen und sagen so hier.
Der kann das der der kann hier mit unseren daten formaten umgehen der hat folgendes protokoll und folgendes und den könnt ihr euch jetzt hier irgendwie installieren.
Und betreiben auf irgendeiner hardware eurer wahl dann dann wird das schon irgendwie laufen so denke ich mal willst du die mittelfristige lösung aussehen,
stellt sich natürlich jetzt die frage was könnte die kurzfristige lösung sein weil man will ja in europa sicherlich relativ bald starten und da wäre dann wahrscheinlich eher die frage ob man sich nicht vielleicht auf eu-ebene auf sowas ähnliches.
Einigen könnte also entweder auch so ein roaming server zu machen wenn er denn dann verfügbar ist oder einfach von vornherein zu sagen.
Was soll der scheiß dann machen wir halt einfach ein eu-logo server und verteilen sowieso alle kies auf alle.
Ist es auch egal.
Also das ist so das was ich da derzeit sehe was ich da tut und ich bin gespannt wann sap und telekom jetzt mal endlich,
dann auch alles releasen es gab jetzt im open source gitter glaube ich nichts neues nochmal ganz kurz schauen nicht dass ich jetzt gerade noch irgendwas,
passt habe aber sieht nicht so aus nee also bisher gibt es immer noch nur den
dieses erste release von dem server und von dem verify server da fehlt also noch dieses portal und es fehlt vor allem halt auch noch die app uns fehlt die android ab.
Ja wenn die da sind wir haben einen halben tag hinsetzen und die mal bauen und.
Selber laufen lassen sollte wahrscheinlich möglich sein dass mit einer mit einem developer.
Zur sein hoffe ich zumindest sonst kann man nur auf den code drauf gucken und die nicht laufen lassen wenn man von äpfeln in gesinnten keyboard möchte.
Die version geht das ja.
Nee denke ich denke ich auch und.
Für jetzt sagen kommt sie eigentlich definitiv zu spät also die wird jetzt die zahlen nicht mehr großartig bei flossen,
aber so eine sache.
Ist mir noch klar geworden auch durch den letzten trosten podcast wo er das glaube ich auch erwähnte.
Das die sache ist ja die wir.
Liegen jetzt irgendwo bei einem null komma acht fünf null komma neun so und.
Im wochenschau und der scheint sich wie wir festgestellt haben auch seit wochen nicht großartig verändert zu haben so jetzt sieht so aus als wenn zumindest im.
Berlin bisschen gerade die die generell auch deutschlandweit.
Die fälle ja ein bisschen hochgegangen sind also wahrscheinlich gibt es irgendwie eine folge der lockerung die man ablesen kann nichts nichts schlimmes sagen solange wir unter.
Unter eins bleiben wobei auch schon gesagt flatten the war jetzt nicht gemeint dass irgendwie die.
Der abfall der kurve verlangsamt werden soll sondern.
Das war die andere seite eigentlich und im moment sieht es so aus als wenn sagen die zahlen nicht so schnell mehr zurückgehen wie.
Sie eigentlich hätten können oder zurückgegangen wären wenn man das beibehalten es macht nicht viel aus so.
Der punkt auf den ich hinaus will ist dass es.
Sehr wahrscheinlich ist dass es eine saisonalität gibt bei diesem virus sprich mehr wenn mehr sonne leute mehr draußen und so dann einfach hat der virus ist schwieriger und wenn's dann,
anschließend in den herbst reingeht so wird der virus wieder ein bisschen einfacher haben so wenn man das jetzt.
Selbst wenn jetzt sagen wir mal.
Durch den herbst also die solidarität wäre nicht groß sondern bringt den um wenn man null komma zwei oder so höher.
Dann ist das aber bei einem niveau von null komma acht fünf plus null komma zwei wäre man dann plötzlich automatisch im herbst über eins so und es heißt.
Die infektion würden wieder anfangen zuzunehmen wenn wir denn noch in substanzieller anzahl gerade aktuell infizierte in der bevölkerung hätten dann flammt das halt,
auf einmal ganz schnell wieder auf so erstmal unbemerkt aber.
So könnte dann echt an fahrt aufnehmen so das ist das ist das eine ding wenn wir jetzt idealerweise in den nächsten zwei monaten die fälle quasi auf null zurückbringen und.
Dann.
Man sagen vielleicht tatsächlich schaffen sagen deutschland erstmal quasi freizukriegen so wie das im moment in man sagen kann dass mecklenburg.
Vorpommern quasi copic frei ist ich glaube zwei fälle oder ein oder zwei fälle im ganzen bundesland wenn wir das auf bundesebene erreichen sollten was ich nicht für ausgeschlossen halte dass wir irgendwie dahin.
Komm tatsächlich dann,
bestünde nur noch nur die gefahr dass in anderen ländern wo es später losgegangen ist oder dies nicht geschafft haben dieses niveau zu erreichen
natürlich dann der virus wieder hier reingetragen werden könnte nach deutschland selbst wenn wir es hier auf null
runterbringen und ja spätestens dann glaube ich könnte die.
Dann plötzlich doch noch mal einen unterschied machen also es ist halt diese knappe kante von von über oder unter eins ja wenn es über die app vielleicht gelingt ein paar fälle,
aufzudecken dass man selbst wie nur um null komma null fünf den erfolg des virus reduziert können diese null komma null fünf genau den unterschied machen zwischen,
es gibt einen ausbruch oder es gibt keinen ausbruch.
Oder es läuft sich schnell zu tode oder es flammt halt wieder auf und insofern ja.
Selbst ein ganz kleiner effekt kann sich dann im herbst als kriegsentscheidend erweisen.
Das denke ich auch also überschätzen sollte man es nicht aber unterschätzen sollte man's meiner meinung nach.
Auch dich und jetzt ist vor allem dann auch erstmal zeit um auch vielleicht etwas entspannter zu testen.
Weiß nicht ganz genau welche möglichkeiten da vorgesehen ist aber irgendwelche möglichkeiten wird's natürlich geben dass man dass die.
Entwickler sozusagen weiterhin testen können andere fälle testen können nähe ausprobieren etcetera unter realen bedingungen,
und ja dann auch vielleicht die ruhe haben die warnungen entsprechend anzupassen
und natürlich was ich für wichtig erachten und das ist auch etwas was ich jetzt gehört habe für die schweizer app das tatsächlich eben über das hier schon mal vermutet hatten mit einer,
warnung also eine exposé notification weißt ja das protokoll letzten endes also dem moment wo man wirklich gesagt bekommt so hör mal.
Wer vielleicht mal besser du lässt mal nachschauen dass damit dann auch wirklich ein kostenloser test verbunden ist.
Also es wird dich in dem fall wo allem die app darauf hinweist dass man damit quasi auch ein garantierten test erhält.
Das ist natürlich auch durchaus eine motivation weil da hat man ja irgendwie einerseits nichts zu verlieren außer zeit aber andererseits kann einem der test ja dann wiederum auch gleich aus dieser quarantäne die dann droht herausbringen.
Und dann denke ich mal wird sich das mit dieser akzeptanz schon in irgendeiner form ergeben welche zahlen man jetzt hier erreicht wie viel leute man jetzt bekommt.
Also ich glaube das ist sehr schwer vorauszusagen.
In der aktuellen es ist ja sommer situation wird es wahrscheinlich mit dem abdecken weile dauern könnte mir vorstellen dass man so aus interesse heraus mit dem richtigen sagen mit dem richtigen ansprechverhalten.
Hatte ich erstmal schon signifikante zahlen erreicht also man sowas wie zwanzig dreißig prozent oder sowas und dann also jetzt aller leute dies theoretisch haben können also,
leute die smartphones haben die ins fahren können ja nicht von.
Den bundesbürger aber ich weiß auch nicht genau wie viel prozent kein smartphone haben und.
Dann wird sich das wahrscheinlich erstmal auf so einem gewissen plateau halten bevor es dann wieder spannend wird für alle und dann muss man halt gucken wie es weitergeht.
Also im moment ist das niveau von neuinfektionen schon in deutschland noch auf eine höhe
so wo sich das durchaus lohnen könnte also es sind halt rund viertausend im moment ja die gemeldet werden pro woche.
Pro woche also neuinfektionen pro woche die gemeldet werden und,
wenn wir jetzt den dunkelziffer,
faktor mit reinnehmen wo ich mich ja für vor ein paar wochen für sechs komma zwei fünf entschieden habe dass das der wahrscheinlichste wert ist jetzt die letzten
sagen offiziellen werte ich gehört hatte waren sechs komma vier so von berufenen seite also ja irgendwo in der gegend
scheint sich das jetzt langsam zu verfestigen reden wir von zwanzigtausend unangemeldetes infektionen pro woche die
wahrscheinlich ablaufen was halt gleichzeitig leider auch heißt das so sich in der letzten woche hundertfünfzig bis zweihundert menschen angesteckt haben die daran sterben werden,
so und insofern ja es ist also es ist nach wie vor mein bei allem zwar.
Nicht mehr so gefährlich wie wie viel früher aber so doch nennenswert und ich glaube so eine so eine app ist immer wenn,
selbst die helfen würde eine handvoll menschen dass die sich früher melden und hier viel früher,
die zum arzt gehen halt auch umso besser die behandlungsmöglichkeiten kann das durchaus ein paar leben retten.
Wenn man stellt sich mal vor es würde jetzt jemand ein bisschen drastisches bild aber ich glaube so ganz falsch ist es jetzt auch nicht man würde sich jetzt mal vorstellen es gäbe jetzt so ein attentäter der fett durch deutschland und er schießt einfach mal so leute.
Und zwar in der größenordnung von hundertfünfzig pro woche.
Was wäre los.
Ja
Ja die leute würden sich ein scheißen wirklich bis zur halskrause.
Kinder von der straße runter panik ja oh gott es kann jeden erwischen hundertfünfzig letzte woche wo er organe.
Und jetzt findet das ganze aber so ein bisschen auf so.
Molekularer ebene statt und hat nicht so diese.
Dieses krasse bild von von von so einem real greifbaren bösewicht ist aber im prinzip genauso gefährlich so und jetzt hast du irgendwie so eine so eine warn-app so attentäter warn-app.
Ist jetzt ein bisschen.
Ist.
Indirekt gedacht so aber die bedrohung ist halt in der größenordnung.
Ja und es ist natürlich dann erheblicher unterschied sagen auch,
sagen irgendjemand bewusst menschen umbringt oder gut bei krankheiten gehen wir halt davon aus es gibt nun mal
krankheiten und eine gewisses risiko aber das ist schon also in dem moment wo man es quantifizieren kann und in dem moment wo man,
ja auch weiß okay da passiert's und da passiert es nicht und aufgrund dessen passierts und aufgrund dessen passiert es nicht ja.
Man sozusagen auch einen einfluss darauf hat da wird's dann natürlich schon interessant in der lage.
Also deine deine zahl mit diesem bisschen in die zukunft schaut mit diese woche werden sich so und so viele leute anstecken die auch dran sterben werden das ist das ist eigentlich so die klasse die man da dran packen kann.
Jetzt wird's für uns natürlich schwierig hier in positiven ausklang zu finden.
Naja gut insgesamt.
Insgesamt kann man kann man es sehen es wird besser in der gesamtsumme es wird besser in den meisten landkreisen,
so das heißt ich sehe schon dass wir erstmal jetzt im hinblick auf den sommer schon sowas wie jetzt auf den letzten metern sind
was jetzt aber natürlich auch heißt so wir können's auch versauen mein wenn's so weiter läuft wie.
Bisher dann also wir haben noch die chance vom herbst wirklich ganz ganz weit nach unten zu kommen und auch vom herbst noch 'n paar wochen normalität,
genießen zu können aber wie es dann im herbst weitergeht,
also bei den jetzigen zahlen so wie sich der virus.
Jetzt aktuell gerade verbreitet unter den bedingungen ist die sozusagen der sicherheitsabstand gerade nicht so super komfortabel hoch also,
so nach allem was ich weiß und und und gehört habe ist die situation schon so dass uns die saisonalität
wieder nach oben drücken kann dass es zumindest auch auch meine überzeugung und insofern
ja würde ich mir natürlich wünschen und es sieht halt auch danach aus dass wir aber so in einem monat
dann tatsächlich hoffentlich in meiner rangliste in der in der landkreistag alle eigentlich nur noch grün sehen das wäre eigentlich der erstrebenswert zustimmt,
vielleicht sollte ich da auch mal eine kurve einbauen war auch schon eine feature nachfrage sozusagen oben dann angezeigt wird,
wieviel den wie viele landkreise denn jeweils sagen wie klassifiziert sind.
Wie die farbe verteiler so einen balken so.
Genau wie die farbe teilung ist und wie die sich dann im laufe der zeit verändert also
ja mehr grün und mehr rot und des und im moment kann ich sagen seit ich jetzt auf die tabelle gucke wird rot langsam weniger und grün halt mehr.
Das vielleicht reicht das ja erstmal als positiver ausblick aber.
Wir werden das auf jeden fall weiter im blick behalten und ich denke ganz ganz laut alarm schreien sollte sich das in irgendeiner form dann doch umkehren.
Ja da müssen wir auch mal überlegen wann wir auf korona umschalten was nix mehr zu berichten gibt das werden wir dann sehen und.
Ja bisher hat sich das ja jede woche irgendwie noch doch gefüllt das das.
Bündel noch ist noch es genug los und ich hoffe aber dass wir ja dass wir bald keinen anlass mehr haben uns hier.
Zu müssen anderen.
Einen anderen anlass haben uns vielleicht zu podcasts zu verabreden.
So sieht's aus pavel dann machen wir schluss für heute.
Ich sag vielen dank wieder an alle für kommentare unterstützung korrekturen hinweise vielleicht habt ihr auch ein paar anregungen
welchen themenbereichen wir uns jetzt noch ein bisschen mehr öffnen könnten jenseits des rheins zahlen apparat.
Mit den apps wird sicherlich nochmal fahrt aufnehmen wenn wir uns dem release nähern gehen juni aber dafür alle anregungen offen.
Ich wollte eigentlich auch noch einen dank hinterher schicken habe ich zwar am anfang schon gemacht aber auf jeden fall ja habe mich vor allem über twitter oder auch hier in den kommentaren immer wieder doch recht hilfreiche hinweise,
erreicht die auch einfach helfen features zu priorisieren oder jetzt auch meinen datenbestand zu vervollständigen vielen lieben dank.
Dafür.
Vielen dank auch für alle unterstützung auch für die spenden für ukw die ein bisschen zugenommen haben und dann hören wir uns nächste woche wieder.